pour fait plaisir de retrouver souffre
yes salut à tous et à l'épier ville bon
ça a été sa muse et il a été sage avec
toi sauf et n'a pas trop endettés ouais
bien comportés
il avait travaillé bon il a fait des
bonnes analyses il n'a pas dit n'importe
quoi pour pour essayer chez pas de
trique et dans certaines positions et
tout ça non il est aménagé
pour le jeu tu l'a recadré malgré le coc
vide tout ça tu l'a recadré moi c'est
cool c'est cool tu vas être content si
on voit ça au replay
[Rires]
est cool cool cool cool cool et bien
c'est le top du top alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a un casque on a aujourd'hui est
ce qu on annonce un peu les gros matches
et et je suis obligé de parler du match
qui est dernier sur la liste mais qui
qu'on va forcément regarder dans la
journée un stouffer on va pas rater ça
et oui le poulain de stouff contre
magnus af tout fais ce que tu veux nous
dire quelques mots par rapport à ça
alors la préparation est secrète
je suis
axé mon coup là mais je suis aussi son
entraîneur comme en tournoi
donc je ne sais pas mais en tout cas je
pense que carson va suer ouais c'était
ma prépa hier était à l'origine de la
prépa stena je fais ce nikov contre
champions que je crois il ya eu débat je
vous ai écoutés dans le début avec avec
sami vous d échanger sur qu'ibm huit
cavaliers 7 mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
pas mal de choses hein depuis qu'arsène
art populariser en match 7 cette ligne
bon qu'est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres matches hyper chaud moi je bats
je regarde jardin devant le forez qui
joue vite eu
petit point sur wayne sur le classement
on sait que la jordan et prague ils sont
soit c'est mal mais voilà notre 2 poule
a ils sont bas bas du classement mais on
va
on va se battre on va se battre je pense
pour pour tous les simples que ça peut
nous amener voilà
parce que dit-il en tête il a quatre
points et on voit que dernièrement dans
l'état la partie il a joueurs un peu
plus solide il a un peu moins chercher
la merde on va dire par ce parti est en
fait c'était ben c'est un joueur qui
vient qui n'en peut plus quoi qu'il
arrive pas n'arrive pas à rester assise
a toujours besoin de renvoyer d'envoyer
quelque chose
ouais c'est dure cinq ans
psychologiquement parce que un jour de
ce niveau là à 2700 lots
je pense qu'il a une tolérance à la
défaite mais une deux ça commence à
faire beaucoup et je pense que trois
c'est plus le même joueur
chez qu'à titre personnel d'ailleurs si
je perds deux parties d'affilée je
commence a tilté stouff pour tout avouer
après ça n'arrive pas tous les jours ça
dépend des tournois mais c'est contre
deux joueurs de mon niveau et ça
commence à vraiment de chauffer et après
je suis moins performant et je pense que
les joueurs de très haut niveau ils ont
une certaine tolérance mais il peut pas
se permettre de perdre une troisième
partie quoi ça me paraît très trop
et ce qui va vous jouer petit bras
d'ailleurs stouff tu pense alors que
jordan normalement il l'envoie mais ce
qui va le tibre aujourd'hui avec les
blancs
pour lui il a gagné
son style donc je je pense pas qu'il va
jouer petit bras je pense qu'il va il va
comme d'habitude voiture avoir une idée
dans l'ouverture et après on verra un
petit peu où ça nous mène mais
at on peut vite comme on dit stuff
oui oui vous savez que c'est quand même
assez exceptionnel est ouf comme je le
disais tout à l'heure a réussi à me
transmettre le qu'ovide pas internet on
se bat on en parle pas assez de ça mais
il a réussi cette perf à avec un début
un début un petit peu bizarre c'est un
début viennois c'est une sorte de grand
vide à m'accepter on a déjà joué au
cices
un peu particulier en nommant je pensais
que ça joue à cavalier m6 qui a essayé
trois ans plus j'avoue que alors que je
le dois évidemment accepté de temps en
temps c'est ouf voilà c'est déjà partir
vous le voyez je suis un petit peu un
petit peu étonné bah ouais bah en fait
je connais pas en fait déjà vous voyez
on est un troisième coup je joue le
candidat max est peut-être temps en
temps et déjà je me pose des questions
ok il faudra augmenter un peu ton volume
apparemment stouff
du coup je vais essayer de jouer c'est
de m'occuper de ça faire de la magie
on va voir on va voir ce que ça va
donner ce que je le fais comme ça où
je peux faire ça normalement up
est le tien ouais ouais ouais je te
laisse commenté donc il faut que
chaudement de le micro de stouff
seyfoullah que j'arrive à faire ça en
live
voilà mais je pense que j'ai tenus hier
on va dire on appelle ça une nul à la
maison c'est là qu'une grosse
préparation
donc on vit à la maison parce que c'est
une ligne qu'il a dû travailler chez lui
et du coup il n'a pas dû beaucoup de
plaisir hier pendant ces partis
donc j'en clan qui est quand même un
joueur à 2710 jaur américain
qui est très talentueux près beaucoup
moins d'échecs donc réussir à faire un
nul avec les noirs comme ça sans qu'on
s'est quand même ça manque quand même
que ça travaille à la maison c'est un
choix exceptionnel ton petit prague
tdc le choper la cam je vais je vais
vous montrer ça si on a la chance voilà
devoir mais d'ailleurs
tu vois
prague bon je sais pas et il en connaît
un rayon comme on dit même s'il est bien
plus jeune que nous il travaille
énormément les échecs mais même là tu as
vu dallaire assez assez perplexe sur sur
la cams tout fait je pense qu'il n'a pas
vu ça tous les jours et un autre
n'hésite pas dans le chat à me dire si
c'est mieux en tout cas j'ai essayé de
faire une petite manip en direct
et tu me diras si ça te plaît si tous
fait encore plus fort si la russie m à
me rattraper et sinon je peux réguler
aussi mon
mon micro bon après ils vont peut-être
transposer dans dans un grammy dame a
accepté là avec avec cavaliers f6 on y
serait on y serait déjà on va dire et
il ya une partie qui m'intéresse pas mal
est ce que tu peux aller voir bien sûr
bien sûr avec la ligne avec grand
plaisir
la même carte scène grandiose qui
vachement à la mode et donc j'ai
travaillé il ya peu de temps et
d'ailleurs je
regarde comment arriver là parce que ça
parle à stouff voilà il a bossé et du
coup
est rousse merci à toi pour ton petit
mot
moins de 20 de moins de 23 niveaux sont
bloqués ben may alors on va voir ça on
va voir ça promis la jemaye la position
alors on est dans un ciel ouvert jusque
là tout va bien ses formes de 6 yens
karine time and of presence apporte
plusieurs noms bref là la sicilienne e6
à six grands classiques on met la
d'avancé 7 c'est sa bonne case pour
compenser les cases noires hélas tous
fils à bosser et c'est ça que tu as
bossé souffre g4
elle étouffe il monte ses bras quand
c'est comme ça que gros g4 envoyé un c
pour travailler puis on va souvent aux
c'tés les pièces comme ça j'imagine
souffre pour après envoyé peut-être ou
de même froid
dans le dos
de jouer les noir et blanc on sent la
rose déjà qu'elle valide les cas c'est
de vraiment
je veux contrôler cavaliers f6
bas pendant qu'il va y ait des huit
cavaliers si j'aurais souvent j'ai cinq
hectares et est en tout cas manger qu'un
de ses hyper intéressant on avait ça
contre s'était présenté devant les lions
ce rapport ou dans deux salles une très
bonne position sur cette prometteuse et
après ne sait plus quoi faire et a fait
un petit peu n'importe quoi et l'autre
partie caudal s'était dégradée 12 carats
scène est donc là on a vu un kart scène
qui a et qui a balancé deux pions longue
ouverture qui s'est déroulé entre une
préparation un petit peu osée et
apparemment
il est passé par perdre en un an son
parti
et est donc là on revoit cette ouverture
encore et si penco contre ce en quoi on
va essayer d'être intéressant de voir
que cette ligne elle est utilisée à
trois reprises dans ce roman
et c'est un peu une nouveauté a été
jouée par grandes loges beaucoup de fois
à la demande viendra je ne sais pas te
dire qui s'assied qui rend ou mais il y
avait maintenant qu'il avait mis à la
mode aussi est donc là j'avais aussi une
partie en direct je pourrais d'espagne
par équipes que je vais maintenant que
j'ai participé avec mon copain en équipe
fabien les budgets ce qui est venue
jouer avec moi donc c'était libye jet
ski blanc contre
santos ruiz donc un grand maître 2006 en
2110 maintenant un jeune et je crois que
c'est la même partie donc et b5
bien sûr donc b6 normal de contrer un
stupa ce que toi tu m'attaques allait
droit donc j'ai envie de toi quelle dame
qui avait foncé 6 dans trois dames des
deux thématiques aussi qu'avant les
processus cambaie 5 arrive parce qu'on
est jamais pensé si ce n'est jamais
possible pour faire un énorme centre
donc la dame trompions français dépend
des cas dans ces structures la dame des
deux enquêtes le coup critique parce
qu'en fait et 20 après après l'es4 le
pur 4 miles sera pas défendue et mais
c'est normal tout ça c'est normal c'est
pas une gaffe de et si bien qu
on a développé finalement champions il a
développé que saddam donc comme on est
très très bien développés à gré blanc et
qu'on menace de faire grand roque
rapidement c'est en fait c'est une
position dans me1 c'est vraiment comme
ça qu'on peut voir les choix je pense
tout fait ça
mais il ya énormément de tours gers et
le bon coup menaces ou des menaces que
j'ai deux attention à tour à 8 voilà et
s'il ya plusieurs coups mais le bon coup
ici c'est comme ces quatre c'est le coup
de sang clan ben vous voyez là 1h46 il
connaît ses classiques champions et
travaille beaucoup si on peut dire
je connais ouais c'est ça ben voilà un
nom les grands maîtres ils connaissent
bien mieux que les mettre la théorie en
force et là on parle des grands mail de
tout premier plan
avant de
faire ça moi je t'en prie
en fait ici il ya plusieurs coûte bon
sur des cinq
manches donc du coup il ya des coups qui
existe il ya dame sait si ces dames
bessette à la place de jouer deux dames
c4 et dans les deux cas il ya beaucoup
de jeu en fait tu vas jouer avec avec
fougue et 2
je joue pour qu'on voie un petit peu
d'âme ses six donc fou j'ai deux tu
provoques des cinq hockey barre et j'ai
pas le choix on voyait tous et après nos
pleurs l'agen
c4 ou des choses comme ça pour attaquer
directement ou
des cadets les d4 4,5 d'accord donc
voilà et en pratique c'est très
difficile parce qu'en fait les noirs ont
du mal à s'entendre pièces et les noirs
sont calmes on retarde développement
mois fait grand cas c'est fini mois de
l'homme blanc est en fait la pression
qui va s'ouvrir toi t'as rien sorti et
même fait petit rock et la suite après
et dames bessette c'est un peu la même
genre donc je pense que des fois car il
veut venir en ange et 3,5 ses dépens que
je veux même cavalier de quatre
cavaliers 5 il ya plein d'idées et c'est
très tactique ce
qu'on peut dire pour les joueurs
amateurs qui nous regardent c'est que
c'est une position qui pose problème
c'est vraiment la théorie moderne pour
les joueurs d'échecs on est quasiment
obligé de connaître ses positions par
coeur je n'aime pas le terme par coeur
mais au delà de connaître les plans les
noirs se joue sur le fil avec leurs
pions de plus s'ils ne connaissent pas
tout ils peuvent avoir de gros gros
problème puisque ce sont des lignes très
tactique très calculatoire où on peut
perdre la partie sur un coup on peut pas
se reposer tranquillement sur un joli
jeu de construction
là il faut être très précis et c'est
bien d'avoir préparé ce genre de ligne à
l'avance à l'ordinateur de tout
connaître
c'est une logique de coup par coup et
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque des dinosaures
ça n'existait pas comme comme variante
il y en avait mais beaucoup moins
maintenant il ya beaucoup de ventes
comme ça qui sont sur le fil et c'est
quand même pénible il faut être joueur
pro est passé du temps à étudier la
théorie pour gérer ce genre de line
hockey dont il ya eu cavani g3 le par
coeur c'est pas forcément c'est pas
efficace et pas bon pour quand vous
doublez d'échec ou même à bas niveau le
par coeur c'est pas bon c'est même
contre productif ce qui vaut faire c'est
vraiment comprendre ce qu'on fait et
pourquoi on joue tel ou tel coup ça
c'est très important par contre au delà
d'un certain niveau
l'étude d'ouverture et le parker devient
obligatoire parce qu'il ya des lignes
comme celle là qui sont très très chaude
et à osny aux banques on doit changer la
capacité des pouvoirs à partir donc un
vent donnait vraiment si on veut être un
bon gros chèque vraiment un moment donné
on doit passer par là quand même mais
mais c'est pas du tout
quand on débute
dans le chacha rose qui nous dit ouais
c'est une variante d'équilibrisme on est
complètement d'accord avec toi c'est ce
que
tous furent relais bah c'est pour ça que
les genres niveau peuvent se permettre
ces variantes d'équilibrisme ce qui me
comprend compréhension très fine mais
quand ils sont dans l'ouverture souvent
ils ont d'énormes connaissance dans ses
variantes d'équilibriste justement parce
que là même un joueur de très haut
niveau vue de les principes ne sont pas
du tout respectés ils ont intérêt de
bien que de bien comprendre parce que là
il met pas en jeu un blitz surclasse
comme s'ils perdent hyper ils perdent
une partie dans un tournoi hyper
important ils peuvent paris match est
derrière donc ils ont intérêt pour se
lancer là-dedans d'avoir des sacrés
connaissance donc dames c'est ça le
grand roque on est dans ce que tu avais
dit un stuff
pour l'instant et les noirs sont en
retard de développement l'urgence est
donc de développer cette pièce là et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu cavaliers aux
sept
cavaliers f si ça devait être défaillant
à cause de jets 5 on peut imaginer en
tout cas
j'essaie de te sortir de ce
regard des cavaliers sept cavaliers à
chaque gène le fouet fuite parce que si
les noirs leur objectif c'est de se
développer et peut-être de roquet est de
valoriser ainsi lors qu'ils ont de plus
à terme mais l'objectif des blancs c'est
que la partie n'aille pas en finale et
c'est de mettre une pression incroyable
sur
le joueur noir bon apparemment champion
de koné 1 la logique qui joue pour
améliorer le cavalier développer le foie
f8 food et 4 comme ils ont joué très
vite on peut passer en revue pendant que
tout va nous sortir ça pique prépa
maison la petite prépare maison de
souffre aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas eu cavaliers f4 en fait
s'ils ont joué cavalier g3
naturellement j'aurais joué cavalier f4
ça paraissait je sais pas plus naturel
mais ça peut retomber peut-être parce
qu'après la postant cavaliers à chaque
henry schein pardon du coup
on doit pouvoir retrouver ce la
vodka des lieux c'est parce que dans ma
base j'écris les f4 pour l'excavation
et dames c'est cette rock apparemment et
si bien qu'on s'est trompés par rapport
à la prépa de stouff voilà il va se
faire charger qu'ils préparent aussi
leur 3 tu prépares prague et si penco ou
pas tous ou tu prépares que prague et tu
peux nous dire où 10 août à part
peut-être c'est top secret peut-être
c'est top secret top secret mais voilà
mais un quart et
voilà c'est ça c'est ça que je pensais
dans les fichiers j'ai bon
mais il ya des cinq qui est mauvais ce
jour est affublé de cette égérie et
bêtise et ouattara tapas aux cavaliers
des cinq lacs ayew 7 qui a aidé 5
mais sur cavalière 6 par exemple à la
place de cavaliers que cette hausse est
donc joue cavalier h5 quand même donc tu
peux peut-être transposer nantes à
patins pas cette ceni n'a pas ce qu'on
trouvera avec sur karachi à aider 50
transposerait exactement dans la
position de la partie
et j'ai dit
ok donc visiblement
sip qu il s'est trompé
dans la prépa dustov mais il n'y a pas
eu de conséquence n'a pas de conséquence
donc savoir il va pas trop se faire
engueuler parce que sinon ce soir il
avait passé un sale quart d'heure
est en fait
peut-être que oui peut-être que c'est
les joueurs qui vont s'énerver parce
qu'ils vont dire à stouff mais alors
dans ton travail avait pas cavalier des
cinq donc les six pays qu il va
peut-être léon vouloir je sais pas
comment ça se passe et le débrief de
leur parti mais ça risque d'être quelque
chose voilà alors cavaliers à shanghai
où cavaliers des 5
fu des quatre ça paraît logique un
dossier elf ou ici de la pression tout
est logique et là je craque sur fc sion
pourrait purger cinq well as a pour elle
en fait m6 et le coup plus logique parce
que n'est généralement on n'aime pas
mettre les pièces esclave mais sur m6
tous nous propose g5 est ce que la
position commencerai pas à s'ouvrir
complètement m'a sans doute que si et du
coup à un endroit est toujours mieux
donc il a joué tour g8 shankland il
touche à rien ou le moins possible dans
cette position mais je dois vous avouer
katic perso ouais j'ai une grande
affection pour la position des blancs je
trouve facile à jouer une dame des trois
opus qui connaissent les joueurs et jean
claude
connais mieux apparemment encore que si
penco qui prend un petit peu de temps
encore que 1 ça on sait pas tout ça
m'est arrivé aussi je dois le confesser
souffre de bluffer un peu mes
adversaires pour que il rentre dans la
ligne que j'avais prévu et est de mettre
en retard par rapport à eux autant et
quand ils peuvent plus s'extirper de la
ligne et que je sais que c'est il ya
plus qu'une ligne linéaire mais là je
commence à des mythes et les coûts
encore plus vite que pour leur montrer
ben en fait qu'au coach connaissait bien
je connaissais mieux que toi
et du coup j'ai une histoire à van zyl
ans ça me plaît
j'avais joué
aux canaries un open
c'était en 2000 gomis saez qui choisit
bien ses destinations à chaque fois vous
remarquez qui s'en va être pas sauf
quand il fait des échecs il ne fait pas
dans le froid quoi très clairement
vasisht emprise touche découper vous
étiez là bas
moins fort que moi et en fait là je
commence à jouer un grand maître avec
thé noir et donc je commence avec
l'afinitor est en fait mon adversaire ne
savait pas de la fise or c'était nouveau
jeu dépend encore jouer en vrai mais
j'ai beaucoup lu sur internet et tout
mais je n'avais jamais joué en officiel
et du coup mon adversaire
donc moi je jouais avant jeu dragon et
peignoirs et benko donc si un dragon et
gants et benko donc à bengo scindant
billon serez fiers un pion et c est moi
qui réfute et vêtements même très dur à
présent m oui oui moi je gravis 23
j'aime plus non plus souffre on est
complètement raccord complètement voilà
et du coup en fait
je vois que le mec dans la base sur la
file dehors il a joué agressif 7 mai une
ligne qui est très très très tendue
c'est pas réfuter du tout c'est très
tendu ouais je vois je vois de caligny
fin je pense voir de calvin qui parle
avec on a deux pièces pourtour pioncer
quelque chose comme ça comme ça avec
damas où il a amassé que ça ok c'est une
autre en fait tu perds tu es tu peux la
montre et regarde si tu vas au tout
début la partie juste pour pour le
reprendre pour l'histoire
va au début le cap des six
mois je peux jouer le 4 mai
d624 et des eighties il restait trois
exercices de 4 4,5 pardon est ici cavale
f3 moi j'aime bien de
moi n'ont qu'à y laissait tu
es fou ces 4 et 6 mpi qu'il n'y avait
que prend des 4 et d'un prend des 4 es
fou e7 est fou contre 7 est en fait
c'est très très chaud et j'avais vu que
le mec il avait déjà fait ça une fois et
de bouger j'ai préparé cette ligne mais
j'ai amélioré les parties almasy fin
j'ai préparé d améliorer les
particuliers à 2007 j'ai fait une
préparation de ouf de tarés complet je
connaissais tous par coeur une pièce de
plus donc c'est compliqué et c'est hyper
chaud et du coup j'arrive à la partie et
le même coin versailles
il me le prouver pour cavaler f3a alors
je me dis je me dis oh [ __ ]
ouais je vois ce que tu veux dire on va
pas modifier mais le mec qui me joue
cavalier est en cours mais que vous et
moi je me dis merde bon il hume tu veux
qu'on trouvait au pine courroux contre
un truc comme ça
donc là j'ai joué des cistes en me
disant vigeo 4 quoi et ils jouent des
quatre
le poker menteur que poker menteur
chaque coup chaque coup je pas ce genre
de trois minutes à infléchir je me
retiens la tête je ne suis pas sûr tu
vois et je doute à chaque coup et le mec
du coup
une jours donc des quatre des six lots
en cavale est froide et 6 des quatre
cavalières si sûr et là il joue cavalier
c3
est donc là je suis pas sûr de moi et
c'est l'âge où cavaliers 17 arrêts joué
4 et joue au 5 mai chaque fois et du
coup quand on joue une fille dorn avec
quoi inverser ouais du coup il se dit
ouais t'as réussi puisqu'un du coup tu
retombes nantes après pas sauf que le
mec qui se dit quitte à piéger dans
l'ordre de cause je comprends bien
chauffer mon adversaire tu penses qui va
piéger dans leurs deux coups parce
qu'ils pensent que je suis
normalement c'est le cas non non c'est
le cas mais tae bo c'est exactement ce
qu'il fallait et si je comprends bien
donc du coup je fais qu'avaient les 17es
fous ces cas là on est parti quoi et là
on est parti donc moi le pauvre il le
tient la tête et là d'un point dé 4
l'ajout fawcett et en jean fouet cet
effet genre le mec t'es j'ai pris mon
fou
et je garde mes chutes
ohlala holtby soho le genre de bistrot
mais attends attends moi si on me fait
ça je sais me donne presque un tel parce
que je me dis mais le fouet il se fout
de ma gueule le mec parce que le fonds
ait fini peut aller coeur de cette
île après il a pris il a pris pas mal à
croire cette tempo il m'arrête dans les
yeux et d'âge pour apprendre et là par
contre là on a commencé on a cru qu'il
ya joué cavalier de lamm débuté un peu
quand même on a joué la ligne à partir
de vous j'ai joué les 15 prochains coups
atempo le moral pour le mac est dur et
pas les 15 prochains coups parce qu'il
est peut-être mais y avait il ya au
moins dix coups une dizaine de coups
tout impôt est là le mec il a commencé à
devenir tout rouge
le grand maître il est complètement fou
et j'ai fini par gagner la partie 1 à
aller gagner mais c'était une très très
grosse partie c'est
un beau souvenir
non mais c'est super bien comment ça se
passe comme ça qu'on arrive à piéger
l'adversaire ce tout ça fait plaisir
surtout qu'on a bossé et on est
récompensé oui il avait aussi une
histoire c'était romu qui m'avait
raconté
le marqueront l'histoire d'une mère en
compte est la sienne et romu nom qu'on
ne connaît pas tant l'entraîneur de
cannes et fiac leur chef et oui là bas
car c'est ça est en fait bien il avait
une histoire c'était
en grèce et il avait fait pareil avec
jean 1 m est arrivé avec sa avec
saragosse 2-1 sur l'épaule en tongs très
inquiète quand le mec complètement
touristes quoi arrive en touriste à la
partie avait été préparée comme un chien
sur la grèce devra de france
fils de pièces il est arrivé
complètement touristes à la partie est
du coup le mec commença blitz et et
romuald aussi parce qu'ils bossent en
tourisme à la plage toi tu moment donné
je crois qu'il avait bluffé pour arriver
jusqu'à un sacrifice de
c'était assez énorme le fait d'arriver
avec la salle de bain sur l'épaule mais
c'était son adversaire on remue dans
l'histoire qui avait la serviette ses
revenus bah oui commune le petit coquin
en serviette quoi et et après j'avais
aussi encore un truc c'était quand je
suis parti là j'ai joué le dernier la
reddition et tournoi de horse
de rapides le corsica ciel corsican
circuit tu vois en lui qui se joue en
été dans la ville a rapporté de
moins en juillet dernier avant de jouer
en 2006 et donc sans groupes d'âge pour
- eh oui 25 97 avaient et donc j'avais
fait qu'une fois de la partie de la
journée la semaine mal joué j'avais fait
un mauvais tournoi et dernière ronde
joue contre son groupe et a donc été un
peu remonté et gt gt chaud je te prendre
le jaune avait des blancs et je suis
préparé pas mal le matin et j'ai vu que
je plane ligne doit absolument tout et
est donc bon marché arrive et vous avez
là ça y est pareil sur l'épaule star en
tongs c'était vraiment le touriste
complet est en fête imagine des rentes
hyper hyper hyper chaude avec taïwan
avec g3 valence âge 5 prévient qu'un
gros sapin il j'ai l'impression qu'il
m'a un peu plus pour un jambon dense
dans le sens que bas j'étais vraiment
vrai je faisais pas mon tournoi et en
plus j'étais vraiment le touriste
complet qui arrivent en retard à la
partie ça c'est pas ma faute série voire
parfois même on avait la voiture à
chaque fois
mais nous aller retour chaque fois
banque belgique le pilote souffre le
pilote voilà et du coup mon charmant
faire à la partie j'étais j'avais
j'avais la
salle de bain le maillot les kong bref
et le mec je 2025 où on fait les maltais
au centre de l'échiquier et j'ai fait
une partie juste
monstrueuse et mes mains je la vente la
plus critique est la plus chaude parce
que je pense qu'il a dû voir que c'est
qui ce mec il a dit vraiment prendre
pour point charlie c'est
simple c'est un peu ça trouble on a
envie de bâcher le mac
donc vous vous avez retenu que se trouve
n'est jamais aussi dangereux qu'avec un
des tongs et une serviette aulas sachez
qu'il veut en découdre quand il se met
dans cet accoutrement là c'est sa tenue
la plus voilà tenue de combat voilà
exactement
et bah ouais c'est sympa ces petites
anecdotes mine 2 mais oui ça me parle
c'est petit coup de bluff dans
l'ouverture quand on est préparé on sait
que l'adversaire s'il arrive dans notre
truc qu'on va être hyper bien et là on a
envie de masquer et on s'est un peu les
fesses en attendant de voir que si
l'adversaire des mythes ou non ce qu'on
a envie qu'ils nous jouent et des fois
ça se passe bien et souvent
au bout d'un moment on tape à côté 1
c'est rare que ça soit jusqu'au bout je
me rappelle que ma dernière près pendent
atteint le dernier dernier top 12 que
j'avais joué c'était encore à nous et
équipe j'avais fait une super préparons
de glen fear il est rentré dedans il a
amassé 45 minutes et souvent je me dis
qu'en vingt mecs planches 45 minutes
c'est qui va jouer un coup pas terrible
quoi graines avaient planché 45 minutes
en fait il a joué le meilleur coup un
cookie et avait été joué une fois par un
grand maître dans la base en fait
j'avais pas réussi à trouver les
ressources tout simplement parce qu'on
n'avait pas tant que ça j'ai fini par
faire nul mais j'étais écoeuré parce que
j'avais les blancs et cetera je rentre
chez moi et là je vois qu'en fait le
coup n'était simplement pas dans mon
fichier même s'il y avait eu une partie
dedans et j'ai vérifié alors dit c'était
tout à fait correct j'aurais pu m'en
apercevoir mais dans la prépa que
j'avais fait je fais pas regarder tous
les coûts dont glen avait été brillant
sur ce coup là et avaient fait nul
mérité même mieux il méritait de gagner
mais mais objectivement lgt vert puisque
souvent tu sais je trouve qu'on
réfléchit beaucoup sur un coup bas ça
peut vraiment être n'importe quoi quoi
donc
c'est franchement fin franchement
c'était c'était assez horrible ouais on
va faire un petit tour d un petit tour
des stades donc bien là on était loin
confie juste avec cette partie pour voir
où ils en sont maintenant que parce
qu'on voit qui estime qu il est en train
de réfléchir après on ira voir marouane
easy on ira voir les autres on est un
tueur g8 dont j'ai une normale il veut
pas laisser il veut y veut pas dénaturer
sa structure sauf que dam des trois je
titille vas-y bouge un peu tes pions
pour que je puisse m'en filtré c'est ce
que les blancs disent mais je suis un
plantage ou g6 le trou est fils est
contrôlée pour l'instant par cavaye des
cinq donc fou j'ai deux foulées de on
balance masi là il a craqué il a craqué
la pièce alors il devait y avoir des
idées un derrière tout ce que tous les
coups
tous les coups en fait c'est préparer un
g prend un charme fou prend des cinq là
j'ouvre j'ouvre le roi et on peut
imaginer que c'est passait pas comme s
ils vous regardent et tourer simplement
sur fouet cette alors j'allais dire
fouet f6 mes genoux apercevoir qu il y
avait d'un f4 mais bon ok je vais faire
quelque chose dans le style et on voit
que c'est hyper dangereux il faut il
sacrifier peut-être d'un me
3,3
et je te fais un petit truc tattoo
recettes et dames trois touches sans
voix je t'envoie la boxe direct pour des
pour démarrer allez je vais t'envoyer un
truc ouais je vais t'envoyer tours 7
j'ai envie je vois pas pourquoi on
ferait pas ça parce que les cases noires
elles ont l'air des structures regardait
hop on commence la journée avec du
sacrifice et j'ai prévu un petit truc un
petit baveux 3 guily et s'aimer c'est
monstrueux des petites cases noires et
ouais comme dans les nôtres et
après après on va prendre un peu trop à
l'échec si le roi il va en d6 regardez
c'est mieux c'est marrant j'ai au moins
gagné la dame j'ai une tour de moi mais
regardez les tournois pour linceul
participent à l'action et c'est le roi
le roi noir en fait c'est pour ça qu'on
peut craindre sacrifier des pièces
ça va pas on voit ça excuse-moi entre
les cours au pire wade s'ils sont une
variante de réserve comme disent tous et
on peut peut-être mater bon vivre non
d'ailleurs il se barre quand même
ques essaris marque mais souffre à vue
dix règles fouet aux cinq qui nous
sécurise et après on peut chercher mieux
si on a envie
trois des huit voyait toutefois f6
airois fuite annamites souhaitait la
vendre un peu plus chaud donc encore
quand il ya de la machine voyait le roi
va revenir on va inviter la tour à la
fête du coup le roi valet partiront dès
8 on pourra le match avec des meufs
s'ils souffraient fils comme on veut
c'est la cata donc c'est assez mignon
donc on comprend bagley ce sont les mecs
il maîtrise tout ça ils ont bossé
donc ça me chante landes plutôt que de
reprendre la pièce bêtement il a vu fou
bessette comme il vient d'en prendre une
et que son adversaire vient de se
rembourser bah on arrive dans cette
position après deux premiers sets
et se veut un procès
tout rejet cap non
c'est égal là il ya du pion plus à un
pion de plus actuellement pour les noirs
mais leur structure est un peu bizarre
on peut rétablir l'équilibré avec g h
mais dans ce cas-là ça confère une
majorité centrale au noir position hyper
bordélique a jugé
sa durée de bosser par sam shankland
salaire quand même plus facile côté
blanc toujours facile parce qu'en fait
le roi dans sécurité exact le roi noir
en rock il est quand même pas mal ouvert
jean-claude connaît très bien on peut le
dire parce qu'il a plus de temps qu'il
ne l'avait au départ de la partie donc
c'est une préparation
maintenant
je trouve que chip qu il n'a pas raté
son ouverture parce que ils allaient
blanc et il a un bon plus d'autant plus
que le redis peut tenir cette position
avec baignoire sans doute d'ailleurs
puisque ça me chante landes il démis de
ses coûts mais pour nous tout faux en
tout cas on préfère se mettre côté blanc
c'est vraiment plus agréable
ça c'est clair que les noirs j'aimerais
c'est très désagréable et salut à tous
ceux qui nous ont joints qui nous ont
rejoints thé vert néandertal qui nous
avait fait un petit coucou de cosider
voilà et vergers races et les autres un
dock merci d'être avec nous
ok rose tu proposes fois fascisme et en
même temps ce que je vous fais fisc à ce
que tu menaces il ya vraiment une menace
avec ça parce que sinon je vais piquer
un pion un je vais te piquer g4 je crois
en force
tout reproche et 4 ça m'ennuie un petit
peu
après
ouais c'est ça
mais après je vais retour s'est vite tu
vas manquer une pièce est
nettement gh5 oui c'est un vrai un vrai
coup pour ouvrir la position
loup à leur
chagrin ont regardé j'ai cinq fois f6
aussi
way road tu peux faf six tours 8 c'est
bizarre quand est-ce que fois f6 tour
huit dames achètes tu vois stouff
c'est quand même chaud un jeff 7 il ya à
chaque j'ai toujours ce truc là donc en
fait j'aimerais bien enfermer la tour g8
ce que la mienne peut revivre c'était
l'idée nord mais peut-être que tu peux
jouer g5 fuglseth errants qu'après moi
je sais pas c'est chaud
il a plein d'options en fait il a plein
d'options et si bien qu ici franchement
j'aime bien
moi j'aime bien les blancs c'est hyper à
g et shankland il a une heure 46 dans
cette position donc il doit la connaître
et ça lui permettra peut-être de s'en
tirer tranquille tranquille tranquille
ok on continue le tour des échiquiers
quand on nous a demandé un il ya plein
de fans de mauri dit marc andré qui est
acquis et le jeune corse la jaune pâle
qui détient le record de précocité de
pour obtenir le titre de grand maître en
france donc il est grand maître il y en
difficulté dans ce tournoi tout fin avec
un sur six
donc chaque demi point est difficile
dans ces cas aller chercher et j'espère
qu'il arrivera à accrocher un moment une
victoire ce qui doit être son objectif
maintenant qu'il a sécurisé un peu avec
avec deux nuls mais il est quand même
ouais pas dans la forme de sa vie après
faut noter aussi que même le challenger
c'est un tournoi d'extrême haut niveau
puisque c'est que des très forts grand
maître ou des jeunes prodiges comme marc
andry mais c'est vraiment pas le seul
finalement dans ce tournoi by marc andré
les prodigieux mais les autres joueurs
qui sont là sont soit des très forts
grand maître expérimenté soit des jeunes
prodiges comme lui donc s'il est en
forme ça peut le faire il peut faire un
énorme tournoi et là malheureusement ça
a mal tourné dès le début et du coup il
a du mal un petit peu à se remettre
dedans parce que ce qui se passe quand
vous avez peu de points dans un tournoi
comme celui-là comme celui là vous
devenez un peu le client à battre et
du coup les joueurs en face vont essayer
de jouer même avec les noirs de pousser
toujours un petit peu plus de diriger
pas trop en confiance en tout cas ils
ont envie de le battre et ce sont des
joueurs très très fort alors on va le
voir et on vient après dans le à
un petit coucou un petit coucou à marcq
andry
hommes
alors voyons voyons hop hop hop
cavaliers f3 f5 mais il a dû bien bossé
donc on est sur un début réty qui permet
aux blancs de jouer plutôt stratégique
en règle générale et s'adapter à ce que
font les noirs mais c'est pas mal de
jouer cavalier f3 au premier coup contre
un jeune puisque le grand maître
expérimenté nguyen se dit enfin
expérimenté c'est un grand mot mais en
tout cas il est un peu plus âgé que que
marc-andré
ben ça lui permet
de se laisser pas mal d'options et la
marque andry il a fait son petit jeune à
jouer f5 nous landaise bas il a envie de
jouer aujourd'hui un
peu de chance moi j'adore ce coup-là
détroit avec avec vidéo 4 mais
maintenant c'est tellement connu avant
ça a été moyennement un ceux des trois
ou quatre maintenant c'est très connu et
il ya des choses qui sont sortis pour
les noirs mais je me rappelle que
j'avais une des parties carlson là
dessus avec avec les blancs qui étaient
assez convaincante mais maintenant les
noirs savent savent jouer contre système
sinon c'est un système qu'on peut
recommander aux joueurs amateurs qui
jouent assez facilement des 3 4 qui vise
d'aller ouvrir la position puisque les
noirs en fait dès le premier coup
affaiblissent le roi mais contre le
centre donc des 3/4 peut être logique
pour aller directement chasser le roi un
petit peu à la chasse au roi donc là on
est dans quelque chose de classique des
cats et une hollandaise une vraie
cavaliers f6 sekkat g6 donc ça c'est
l'hollandaise leningrad avec le funk et
au et la système marche bien le look
classique cg3 fou j'ai deux ici un donc
ça c'est les grandes variantes le 3
c'est déjà marginal avec un plan avec
bekkat une expansion à l'ale dame ça se
joue aussi des six
fours et 2 petit rock bon pas très
ambitieux pour l'instant le joueur avec
avec les blancs mais bon ok ça se joue
tout à fait et surfe ou aux deux il me
semble se trouve qu'on peut jouer des
choses aussi avait que 5 ce que faut pas
croire que le pion serait réellement en
prise avec les idées cavaliers g4 ouais
ça ces thématiques après je sais pas si
les dames des cinq échecs marche je sais
pas il faudrait vérifier ce que j'avance
mais je sais que j'avais joué une partie
une fois comme ça avec les blancs avec
b3 pour éviter un peu la théorie et mon
adversaire mais jouer a que 5 alors
est-ce qu'il avait déjà le cavalier b en
décèdent pardon et il avait joué en tout
cas sur ce schéma vous comprenez des
princes un cavalier g4 on écrase le
centre adverse et par la tactique
puisque les foules se font face leurs
vis-à-vis sur la diago par cet aspect
tactique on arrive à jouer 5 et
cavaliers g4 bon et pour l'instant il
s'est rien passé
marc andrieux a préféré jouer avec ses 5
il attaque le centre c'est légitime par
contre ils échangent des 4 contre des 6
po sur potentiellement stouff donc je
comprends ce qu'a fait ici nguyen avec
bcdc
maintenant c'est déjà ok petit rock je
suis un petit peu étonné de la décision
c'est 5 en fait pour tout avouer souffle
ouais bien sûr donc faut 2,5 à vérifier
ce que j'avance je connais pas par coeur
cette position elle est un peu rare des
proc la vallée gcard le thème je le
connais bien
hélas tout j'étais en train de me dire
tiens est ce que dan des singles
délirant d'amd 5 pour s'accrocher option
est jouable
ce serait bizarre
quand même façon même sans fin ça change
pas grand chose je crois non mais là je
crois que c'est pas mal enfin le peu
d'argent à gabès et 6 4
non non d'amd 5 c'est juste pour voir
s'il n'y a pas moyen de tenir mais je
suis complètement d'accord avec toi non
mais peut-être que les blancs que je
d'amener 3 puis après peut être un petit
rendez 3 eh bien on va mettre à l'essai
et 6 one way on peut attendre avant de
prendre mais vous voyez on peut regarder
le pion déjà y'a pas de problème et
soufis regarde les coups comme ça pour
rhdp récupérer avec une pièce on a eu
cinq d'avoir un bon jeu de pièces une
position assez agréables souvent
cavalier c6 est un peu plus préférable
en règle générale pour le côté je bloque
pas le fou c'est lui qui devrait aller
re 6
voilà c'est souvent ça kazan dans la
hollandaise
hockey avec une pression par exemple
champions c4 si j'ai repris d'un
cavalier en v5
souvent comme ça après je me rappelle
que le pion en b3 dans ce que je la
regardais la le fait qu'il soit en
bekkat escapades et b5 à certains
moments peut-être mais en même temps ça
lâche des cases aussi mais là un peu
bizarre
pour en revenir tout faux coup avec avec
ses 5 regardez en fait structurellement
j'adore pour les joueurs amateurs qui
nous qui nous regardent ces histoires de
pions et là en fait il faut bien
comprendre que quand les noirs jouent
ces 5 il propose les changes du pion b4
de l'ale dames contre le pion central
des six ça n'a pas manqué un son
adversaire mais français des français ti
rock et du coup ça donne pas envie de
jouer les pions pendant ici avec les
noirs qu'on obtient comme ça avec
s'éprend d'un e prend des les pions
pendant d'options côte à côte et ils
n'ont pas de copain pions sur les
colonnes e et b donc ses deux pions
c'est un petit îlot de pions en fait
c'est dès maintenant il contrôle le
centre ses pions donc c'est pas tout à
fait nul stouff et en plus s'il ya ce
pion le set qui me semble pas beau
et bam marque andry apparemment vient de
passer à s'éprend d'un
petit
sac voilà c'est prendre a été joué et
prend des quoi le condé va
vraisemblablement prendre franchement
c'est un coût qui me donne envie
c'est assez bizarre comme comme décision
je pense aux faibles gelées depuis un an
en fait si vous voulez pour j'adorerais
la position de marc andré le pion à f7
pour moi serait très différent
puisque j'aurai des pions pendant créer
et pas des fléchissements sur le roi une
sortie du fou ces huit facilité et là je
pense qu'on peut le jouer mais avec
l'option f5 cette position est les
bizarroïdes non avec le pion à f/5 on
voit que le plus arriéré de là j'ai
jamais vu cette position pour être tout
à fait franc et vous est donc là on voit
avec à cause du vent le pion aux espions
et cet arriéré et
et aussi l'accès à 15,5 avec une caisse
avec l'option fc comme moins évident et
c'est peut être un fcf et puis il ya
aussi des mélanges qui est ouverte
donc d'un des trois décades aller 5
pouvoir des idées sur la découverte dans
tous les cas c'est vrai que c'est assez
étrange les blancs estiment je pense
oui je sais pas de quoi parler thé vert
pour le est-ce que c'est pas pire
d'avoir le statut de favori niveau
pression ben je dirais que ça dépend
pour qui on voit qu'on quinzaine qui
al'habitude bas il arrive que gérer la
pression sans trop de problèmes
ça dépend des cas mais généralement
quand on est favori et que ce soit dans
le challenger ou
dans le à sec on est rompu un art on
parle des tournois de très très haut
niveau donc c'est plutôt pour des
joueurs moyens que ça peut être gênant
d'avoir le statut de favori sinon sinon
je pense que c'est pas un énorme
problème en fait pour les joueurs que
l'on voit dans ces tournois
exactement et cava lieu 4 j'aime
toujours pas je suis mon train de
regarder cavaliers b d2 avec l'idée est
reprise et cavaliers g5 je sais pas trop
en fait je comprends ce que marc andré
veut faire c'est à dire qu'il veut
mettre une grosse pression rien qu'à et
c6 qui arrive
et il doit sentir déjà que ça va pas
trop sa position sur 15 mai les deux que
j'ai proposé de manière un peu légère il
ya peu de caisse et 6 quand même et ça
va peut-être mais
en fait si vous voulez il il s'occupe
pas de ces pièces là il a envie de créer
quelque chose sur le centre parce qu'il
sait que sa position pour l'instant est
assez moyenne donc il veut jouer assez
dynamique dans la proche voilà donc
voilà tout ok on s'est déjà fait une
certaine idée de la partie cette vaste
ouf on viendra pour pour voir un peu ce
que ça a donné plus tard août avait des
remarques 7 way.com se faire un petit
tour des échiquiers dans le ah
ouais on
tond petits protégés ah bah là ils sont
dans une position
du grand vide à m'accepter un
tu dis là il est bien il est je pense
qu'il est dans son élément le petit prix
non non non non non effet d'annoncé de
ce trophée du coup ça c'est des
positions je connais comme pas trop mal
puisqu'on est retombé en fait dans
dans un gourbi dame accepté après
cavaliers f6 donc lors de coups je
regarderai oui en fait j'avais déjà
regardé quand même une fois lors de quoi
s icd c4 qui est pas si peu fréquent non
plus
et l'idée après bah c'est de faire ses
seins qu'on voit souvent aussi db5 pour
fou bessette qui a aimé 17 fawcett
souffre ou des six enfin ça permet au
noir d'avoir un schéma un petit peu
simple
sur ce prague à jouer sans se prendre la
tête avec
avec mes 3 est en fait b5 et plus
naturel pour les joueurs amateurs mais
pour ceux qui connaissent un petit peu
bessin et que je peux enlever mon fondé
3e 2 et je peux jouer d'ailleurs c'est
être plus simple pour vous parce que
sinon ça va être un petit peu embêtant
mais b5 je m'en fous eux deux ont des
trois imaginons deux de ses points
problème là je vais avoir la rupture à 4
sur quoi les noirs vont normalement
réponse b 4 pour se soulager de la
pression énorme sur b5 et ça permettra
aux cavaliers mais un qui n'a pas tant
de sept cas sur l'échiquier de venir en
d2 c4 et ça franchement le cavalier une
fois qu'il est postée en c4 il se régale
il a vraiment une très belle case et du
coup ça peut être un petit peu un petit
peu embêtant voilà tout simplement donc
magnus à s'explique il a joué b6 s'ils
gagnent pas le tempo sur le fond ces
quatre mais le fossé 4 tape sur du dur
donc c'est pas c'est pas trop grave et
et du coup c'est on arrive à comprendre
cette histoire
d'enlever manuellement je pense qu'il se
passe ok du coup b3 b6
x 3 déjà ce trail jeu x 3 1
normalement j'ai plus l'habitude de voir
le fou en b2 mais bon en même temps on
comprend vous voyez la petite astuce de
fou prend un fuite et il empêche ces
prendrait quatre et peut-être qu'on va
créer un pion faible en prenant ces cinq
voiliers vide et structurelles se
dégager un le jeu avec les pions mec
super
intéressant parce que vous n'êtes pas à
votre question parce que en fait pour
tout faux à droite menace moment de
manger en c5 et du coup de créer un
tueur isolé si les noirs mange vraiment
des quatre vingts je mange la fuite
c'est des rockets et du coup il faut
défendre ce pion si tu veux l'éviter
désolé et des rockets donc avec aval et
b17 qui est la partie
krebs est de bien jouer bah évidemment
un carrousel connaît et maintenant ils
avaient des cinq descentes directes
oui alors ce qui paraît un tout petit
peu étonnant vous le voyez je pense
qu'il offre à magnus il offre sa paire
de fou bien sûr il ya toujours une
carotte dans ces cas là
on peut imaginer surprendre et vous
prenez ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs
dans la partie tout cas et prend des
comme ça n'a pas été le jouet on peut se
poser la question et cavaliers prendre
et d'en prendre et j'imagine
il y avait huit sûrement tourbe et 8
août huras est pas ce que tout rebelle 8
c'était peut-être larnack cavalier e 5
enfin larnack entre guillemets je tapais
vii je menace cavaliers c6 est sûre
cavaliers d'un prends ça me fait penser
à une position du benko où il ya des 9,6
là ça met une pression difficile sans
connaître de savoir ce que la position
donnée
mais très intéressant cette tradition on
trace notre dame f6 joué le jeu cette
annonce est à prendre cette fois
désolé ça arrive on en fait
quelques-unes des petites saucisses par
moments vous savez on aime bien
au kef au b2 qui a proposé c'était
vraiment très intéressant et
ouais j'ai déjà quand même en train de
vérifier qu'à et celle ci se trouve qui
me paraît pas si simple
je sais pas car les premiers huit heures
est ce que tu peux bouffer à la tourette
et qu'avant d'y aller toi stouff
joue en fait je voulais faire une petite
peau de banane ces dames 4
en fait je voulais faire qu'à et c6 pour
menacer la tour mais je voulais aussi
menacer damas quatre en même temps après
tu va peut-être jouer tout simplement
damme 6e trophée électorale à faire
après je sais pas peut-être c'est
compliqué
mais là tout était comestible donc non
non on ne peut pas jouer ça donc fou
mais deux très sérieux
il a peut-être 2006
parce que je peux pas trop manger un
set
il apprendra
peut pas il a fait moins d'erreurs quoi
ça peut pas
anda monsieur
ouais donc ça méritait aussi l'attention
dans ce cas là on aura peut être quelque
chose
parce que c'est tentant de piquer la
paire de fou si vous voulez dans cette
position mais je constate que magnus
directement je vais tourbe et 8 en même
temps là et magnus a fait jouer un coup
très intelligent aussi stouff c'est le
fait de il peut toujours prendre des
cinq en fait
c'est à dire que la prime va pas je le
fous ces quatre dans cette position
mais en fait
tomber à 8 il ya eu foule b2
et là je peux encore si je veux faire
cailler prendrait 5
mais c'est peut-être un peu dure en
matière de développement
fomine us il arriva ce dès qu'ils
mangent le food et 5 c'est bien
stratégiquement mais le four b2 ça y est
il sort donc maintenue soit il joue pour
ça soit il joue peut-être plutôt fou e7
est petit rock
avec l'idée de ne pas laisser cette
diagonale ouvert parce que sinon s'il
prend des cinq ça peut vite être être
pénible à ce niveau là au niveau du
développement de son fouet fuite si le
fouet fils ne se développe pas et ben
vous l'avez compris aura pas de petit
rock du coup c'est une mission difficile
à prendre qu'à elle prendrait cinq
peut-être fou de cette aimé à ce
qu'avait des programmes d'apprentissage
ouais tout à fait tout à fait sous feu
ça part et ça
paraît intéressant et puis là-bas a pris
beaucoup de temps en magnus donc il peut
réfléchir dans cette position est-ce que
je peux jouer un coup comme poussettes
et aux 4 c'est cette thématique
normalement mais je mange du pion ouais
alors
du coup qui va manquer blanche je
comprends bien que le pompon est faible
mais
pas fou mais de
j'avais pas mis à jour mais regarde tous
mes deux il ya eu bien il ya bien eu
fouet cette toi tu nous proposes et
souffre 4 que j'aimais beaucoup mailhac
à épron dessin je pense quand même un
petit rock et le goût prague il a
préféré cas et c3 et petit rock et
j'adore en fait ce que fait magnus
par rapport à un principe tu sais c'est
la maîtrise de la tension il considère
que le fou ne va jamais en c4 que là il
aurait même b5 à la limite très
intéressant au foot bessette et du coup
il le laisse un peu son
on s'en fout des cinq comme ça en plein
milieu on se demande un peu ce qui fait
je pense que magnus a déjà a déjà
presque égaliser dans cette position
après que s'est passé un truc bizarre
parce qu'au début tout à l'heure je
voyais que la partie de double français
par irie du bord
et vous voyez des 4 bulgarie et du waf
qui venait pas zéro forfait
peut-être
je sais pas il peut y avoir un covit je
sais pas j'ai pas le poids c'est oui
c'est ça maintenant vous le savez un
toufike ovide moi j'ai le coc vide aussi
et dans le chat j'ai vu quelques vidéos
ci
il va être très très fort ouais ça c'est
sûr que prague way très très fort
il est possible que
ça voilà d'indigo way malheureusement
pour lui n'avait pas fait le tour des
calmes mais là jamais dû se présenter je
pense
alors si je fais le tour des calmes 1
016 jamais présenté
ouais
ben sacré news il dirait qu'il va
ça craignent aussi
dans le classement venir
mais c'est pour double arrivée
alors que
moi dans des tournois de haut niveau ce
qui est en fait ce qui m'étonne si tu
veux souffle c'est même si les maladies
prévient l'organisation donc il ya dû
avoir un truc quoi il y avoir un truc
pour avoir un petit peu les réseaux
qu'on vous laisse vtv réseau et sinon
nous on regardera la pause pour vous
donner en courant mais
420 ont voulu qu'il joue avec de masse
mais il a refusé par principe il a fait
un test rapide négatif et est sans doute
tout un pcr
qui est bon et puis comme jacques hamas
qu'un la fragile gars masque parce que
son entraîneur il est il à locaux vides
mais un jeu comprend que jegham
accession mais bon juste non mais j'ai
pas compris pourquoi elle a refusé par
principe en fait c'est le cas le
principe c'est que sportivement il était
avantagé c'est ça surement savez mon
frein c'est de pas trop vite que justin
pandémie
bon en tout cas c'est ce n'est pas une
super pub pour pour les échecs
ça c'est clair mais c'est compliqué
puisque à ce niveau là bas les joueurs
ils ont leurs exigences et on voit que
l'organisateur je pense il a essayé de
trouver la meilleure solution pour
contenter tous les joueurs et
malheureusement ce n'est pas passé la
bizarre quand même bizarre bon c'est
comme ça
c'est le communiqué des organes side et
il relaie l'info c'est il ne juge pas
l'info
ok allez on va aller voir les les autres
partis pour répondre à route quand même
parce que quand on parle de
votre chauffe là on chauffe
bains prague en fait
bon en fait moi j'avais fait un stage
avec l'équipe de top jeunes avec romuald
et on avait vu prague était là il était
encore et me lapp 2480 il avait 13 ans
ne rigolait pas déjà le court il faisait
l aveugle et c'est pas une blague en
fait en fait le course tu veux tout
l'été d'avoir vraiment dans le même dans
la même salle genre y avait des joueurs
26 ans est lui aussi quoi et en fait
issu et le même court sauf que lui
faisait la règle est en fête avec vous
avez le dos tourné les chéquiers et est
calculé
basta intégration comme une manière de
terre et en fait ils travaillent
énormément énormément le calcul donc là
tactiquement c'est une bête tactique
prague et mais lui il est un peu
particulier par rapport aux autres si tu
le compares un petit peu à bout kesha
charyn etc j'ai l'impression que prague
est beaucoup plus positionnelle et il
rentre beaucoup moins dans le dollar et
il est plus professionnel prophylactique
il aime beaucoup bonne foi la partie
qu'il a fait contre
grand déluge basse et masterclass
précieusement et
c'est à mon client plus comprendre
master class grandiose puisque l'huile
est plutôt hyperactif et disco le joueur
polonais c'est malin donc en fait il est
il est hyper positionnelle
mes calculs très très très bien et donc
il peut à tout moment dans les positions
incontrôlable pas compliqué il ya pas de
souci en fait il est audacieux oui il
n'a pas peur il est jeune il y aussi des
forts et je vous progressez
enfin sa chance est en tout cas
[Musique]
ouais un peu de temps après pas mieux
ces attaques
c'est que en fait ce que veut dire se
trouve ce qu'il a plusieurs
styles c'est à dire qu'il est très fort
dans le calcul donc normalement on va
plutôt à les valoriser dans l'aspect
tactique des choses et lui peut jouer
des parties plus plate en fait il a pas
il va pas nécessairement
faire flouer
partir trop vite quoi l'attaquent c'est
ça que dira peut-être par préparer mieux
ces attaques ouais ouais c'est ça
auditionné l'aide ça veut dire qu'il va
essayer de plus plein de mieux placer
ses pièces jouées vraiment sur le long
terme et sur l'amélioration des
positions sont pas cependant des pièces
quelques données ouvertes toutes ces
choses là les aspects qui peut être bon
ou mauvais four à tout ça plutôt que de
calculer et trouver enfin est calculé
comme un coma tard et
doit donc lui balancer g4 bon ça peut
être un client a balancé g4 qui
attaquait comme un taré mais
généralement il est quand même plus posé
il préfère les positions plus tranquille
ce qui était plutôt bien d'ailleurs
c'est une grosse qualité pour un jeune
joueur puisqu'il faut très vite tout à
voir à ce niveau là généralement ça
c'est un atout que tueur un peu plus
tard twain parce que c'est quand même
celle rapport à la maturité de
comprendre que dans cette position ne
veut pas trop attaquer qu'il faut plus
et être très très bon niveau
professionnel aussi jeune c'est quelque
chose qui est
je sais pas comment je vais faire pour
vendre aussi bien de genre de nos ventes
forest souffre
[Rires]
mais j'espère que j'ordonne va se vendre
tout seul
en sortant une énorme partie contre
visite et d'ailleurs je te propose
d'aller d'aller voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe parce que sinon tout va se
focaliser sur sur ce petit prague
voilà qui a joué qui a joué dans ces 2
qui compte bien posté sa tour en d1 pour
poser la question pièce noire ce que les
noirs ont quand même des moins de
facilité de développement que les blancs
donc voilà
c'est ça aussi est ce qu'on va faire
tous rêvent d un autour a des seins est
soit mal d'atouts anciens ce qu'on veut
les deux sont possibles tous propose un
plan assez naturel en fait tour d un
tour eu un tour d un voilà et après le
pied 4 et je peux pas depuis tout à
l'heure tous fait hacher pas ce qui se
passe tag est pas sera vu à la pas vu
mais il ya eu plusieurs
le clic manuel depuis que pour tout
avouer qu attaquer un peu dépassée
depuis que j'ai réussi à faire des
flèches bleues j'étais tout content
je crois que j'ai fait un petit plaisir
l'échiquier du coup je me vantais pas
trop mais bon comme tu as pris en flag
choses bougent et m'en parler je
comptais je compte annoncer ça
discrètement à la pause au fait ya pas
un truc pour machin et voilà non mais
j'étais en train de me ce qui m'excite
et voilà ça fait toujours partie de la
magie
voilà une petite titre régalade encore
alors on avait dit qu'on allait voir
jordan qui jouent contre visite à l'est
j'ordonne aléas les blancs est encore
bien préparés vraisemblablement
puisqu'il à 1h36 alors que vie dit il
est à 54 minutes
on regarde un petit peu cette ni maison
ni museau alors nîmes zoo c'est des
quatre cavaliers f6 ses 4 e 6 e mail
salhany museau indienne
la grosse idée c'est sûr qu'à et ses
trois fous b4 et on contrôle
indirectement le centre puisque la puce
a4 est rendue impossible à cause de la
pression et du courage qu'exerce le fou
bekkat ça ça se comprend donc a essayé
trois fouilles b4 du coup je suis obligé
de manuellement enlever les flèches qui
est toujours assez rigolo
j'entrais voilà
donc d'homs et 2 cdh à rendre classique
pour jouer pour eux 4 à terme en tout
cas contrôler cette case là c'est
vraiment logique comme coup alors qu'un
coup de dames en général dès l'ouverture
c'est pas très bon ça permet aussi la
sacu multifonctions poussé quatre
contrôler la case 4 et
ne pas casser la structure et de
reprendre la dame en c3 voilà et on
pourrais je fous des deux mais on on
veut mieux pour ce fou normand qui va
vraisemblablement les hanches et 5 donc
petit rock a été joué comme des bulles
sellem début je vais toujours sur frag
mais la partie rapport rapport prague
c'est une des grandes classiques on va
dire fou prendre dans prend hélas la
variante qu'on connaissait tous tes b6
dans les années 2000 2010 et ça a été
supplanté par des cinq qui se jouait -
avants qui a pour objectif de d'ouvrir
le centre alors que le roi eu un bain
n'a pas fait le taff les blancs réussi à
piquer la paire de fou normalement c'est
pas au noir d'ouvrir la position par
rapport à cette perte de foot possède
les blancs mais dans cette situation le
facteur du roi le critère du roi bas est
supérieure à cette histoire de père de
phù dông les noirs ouvre comme la
position pour essayer de faire mal au
roi donc des cinq qui est bon et ouvre
sur blanc un pour l'instant ouvrir sur
blanc dans cette position c'est tout à
fait c'est tout à fait jouable puisque
j'ai trois pièces mineurs dont le [ __ ]
case blanche donc je suis en supériorité
numérique de pièces mineurs sur 15
blanche donc faire une rupture sur blanc
c'est dans l'école de stratégie tout à
fait acceptée voilà donc c'est pas une
ouverture sur noirs et les blancs vont
essayer de profiter des cases noires
puisque ce sont les seuls à voir le fou
distinctif de cases noires j'espère que
vous avez bien compris parce que j'ai eu
du stress qu'on appelle le jeu de
couleurs esquissé une des notions
importantes aux échecs dans le milieu de
jeu puisque on échange souvent fouet
cavaliers donc du classique dépensé 4
j'ouvre sur blanc et jouve tout la
position pour dire bonjour aux rois ou
des blancs d'un procès ktb 6 souvent
l'idée c'est le petit guy dufaux à 6 le
petit c5 aussi pour ouvrir toute la
pause et dire bonjour au roi fou g5 a
été jouée on on attendait ce coup
et c'est fou bessette qui a été préféré
qui empêche toute idée à base de 4 c'est
assez normal cavalier e 5
d'amd 6
et 3
bon c'est une position tout à fait
commune et la vie dit il a joué
il a joué avec ses 5
je suis un peu étonné que visite soit
entre guillemets or théorie stouff
schémas ci est vraiment hors théorie
mais il a quand même consommé énormément
de temps
je suis un petit peu étonné parce que je
vois pas trop pourquoi
si tu veux et je vais vous mettre la cam
d'ailleurs on
en l'occurrence deux de nos amis voilà
donc je redonne est
évident dit voilà
ouais mais bon
ça doit être ça doit être vraiment
travaillé par
par jordan puisqu'il a joué très très
vite comme un ouais
c'est après c'est un peu s'attendent à
ce qu'ils ont fait
vous voyez aussi quelque chose de
bizarre peut-être sait qu'à tout moment
j'ordonne pouvait manger le cavalier f6
et vous vous avez vous dire ça ouvrait
le roi noir mais les blancs n'avaient
pas plein de pièces pour attaquer le roi
noir et d'autre part on aurait été
obligée d'enlever notre cavalier e 5 une
fois la reprise effectuée par les noirs
donc c'est quand même un petit peu
dommage
donc 3 et tient son pion des 4 es là bas
sa vie dit de se développer assez
rapidement visiblement
les connaît j'ordonne pourtant je vois
pas trop en quoi il est il est largement
mieux s qui lui met la pression
si les noirs il va sortir car il aimait
8 ya toujours fois ci ce qui est
d'actualité un mine 2
met la pression oui peut-être qu'à un
moment il va sortir son fouet les c'est
fou pranger 2 pour faire tourner ça
c'est possible
ok on a des coups candidat quand même
assez logique avec les noirs tout cas et
b17 souffre
paraître assez normal ici
cavaliers c6 s'éprend des quatre
proposés par stéphane pour directement
directement créés un peu isolé pour
dent sur ses projets que l'on croit une
tour ses 8 ans je peux
tout à fait qu'outre est intéressant ça
c'est sûr ce que je peux jouer la finale
avec un pied isolé n'a pas joué sous
était intéressant de voir way
voyez une petite avance et là d'un coup
voilà c'est cinq
fois f4
donc oui l'a pas laissé il a pas laissé
dont la rocqué ya plein de tact et vous
voyez kg 6 et cetera du ku'damm 7
décès pour pas laisser le sait prendre
et quatre en fait ses fans n'y a pas eu
un
cette possibilité la tour c 8 assez
légitime pour garder l'initiative fout
de
tout reproche et 5 pour moi c'est normal
j'attaque la dam dam des cats hockey et
maintenant cavalier des 5es
non juste qu'il y avait toujours ce
fameux pions en rouge en ange et deux
pions visiblement pour raisonner parce
que si je le prend directement il ya pas
de l'idée tour g1
avec
avec du jeu
sur le
dangereux
patron voulait prendre parce qu'après ça
où les colonnes sur notre roi voyez hein
ça peut être dangereux
regardez à ce moment-là fou projet de
tour g1
et du cou
kefu bessette a l'air normal
comment on pouvait faire mal donc on
voit évidemment les x chis
il ya aussi cette case là qui peut qui
clignote aussi
si ce geste vous
des cloisons
way qu'elle gcard même directement aussi
qui est intéressante on sur la
fourchette 1,5
après qu'il y aurait du jeu sur le roi
noir et du coup vie qu'il a pas envie
d'avoir des positions et patar jeu
solide ouais c'est trop risqué
à un autre me fait penser au public
hautement oublier les pubs
la pum peut effectivement avoir
toutes les armes on a commencé à 1h08 ok
vous savez les gars on
traite autour des 6 6 minutes je vous
rappelle
allez je vous en vous envoyant en pub je
vois titres comme saint pas une petite
qu'est ce que je peux vous mettre la
folie quoi
[Musique]
donc
on
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
à
[Musique]
allez et nous revoilà
on est
reparti pour les commentaires du tata
steel compte 7 il ya déjà une partie qui
s'est terminée à la surprise générale on
a parlé puisque c'est
comment dirais-je bas du beauf qui a qui
a fait forfait ça ça fait un petit peu
mal
à cause du coc vide qu'à contacter et
cetera donc voilà il ay l'a fait il a
fait forfait et on va filer maintenant
sur une nouvelle partie on a pas mal
partait de là pas parler de la partie le
jardin de vente forest on a aussi parlé
de la partie 2 de magnus et on revient
sur
chants clandestine kohoué cipango
shankland avec une avant tu n'avances
autant qu'ils continuent de croître pour
sa malchance landes alors que on aimait
beaucoup hein
la position d'andré ici penco et il a
joué un des coups possibles dans sap
avancés des mains scindant dans la
position un peu plus que je ne pensais
mais
exact exact stouff on se poser des
questions par la gc10 badgés prochain on
y avait le plus on achète en l'air il ya
pas mal de choix il y a eu donc j'ai
prend un chien qui ouvrait la position
de manière assez assez importante sur ga
je crois que c'est le coup tu proposes
est d'ailleurs tour g1 tour g1 avec le
pion achètent toujours en l'air dam des
cinq a été jouée c'est logique ça fait
pression sur le fou des cadres le pion à
deux ça empêche aussi la dame d'aller en
achète donc ça on comprend assez
aisément et du coup dans cette situation
au tibet trois
joueurs parce que le fou peut retourner
larroy bien tout est à moi j'aurais
plutôt eu tendance à jour ou bien on
voit bien où
ça m'avait la battait les
dracs maison leroy ambert pour dépendra
d'eux voilà tous les échecs
on croit bien
sâr construit même le une sorte de petit
rock hotel dames le fait froid bien
il a fait b3 bon là y'a pas de problème
de maths du couloir entre guillemets ce
qui peut être très intéressant si on
compare par rapport aux pourquoi il n'a
pas joué roi bien on a ce genre de
qu'autour g8 qui n'était pas possible à
groix bien qu'il le devient maintenant
quand je dis tour g8 s'est tous les
coups de tours 1
dans ce genre de position
donc c'est ça la différence fondamentale
ouais voilà ce qu'on peut dire s'est
passé quoi parce qu'après je veux qu'ils
avaient un plan qui arrive à 5 voilà il
ya eu ff5 sur b3 et dames 3 et là on est
dans la position
dans la position de base la f5 ça paraît
logique ça ça défend h7 voilà à la
menace d'un procès qui est toujours bon
pour la santé par an une menace parce
que le fou des cathéters emprise mai
autre point à surveiller cette rs5 donc
je sors cases blanches
et d'un meutre
d'un me 3 vient d'être jouée par les
blancs pour des clous et entre
guillemets le fou parce que c'est un
vide de se prendre d'un programme dont
le fonds peut sortir et on empêche aussi
les idées à base de foie chis
d'ailleurs l'affouage si c'est un coup
bas en fait je le regardais mes dames
1er tour g8 ouailles mais ya pas de père
fait sur le web parce que je pensais en
fait avoir dans prendrait quatre
derrière g8 pire enfilade
on a en fait ici le plan des blancs est
intéressant parce qu'en fait c'est très
simple ce qui veux c'est jouer en fait
levé 2 et probablement autour des indes
arrière vautours g8 mais il veut
vraiment déjà commencé par
regarder liés à la dame et le et le four
adam pour l'instant et comme il se doit
rester ici pour défendre le food et 4
une fois que ces foulées 2 et baladin
pourra bouger et en fait l'idée c'est
qu'une fois que je joue four b2 et b3
blanc il est hyper safe il est hyper en
sécurité toutes les pièces jouent bien
accrocher les noirs masserey il ya même
un problème sur le roi 8
on sait pas encore à quoi bon il va
aller quoi
est donc en fait je pense qu'avec des
grands fauves et 2 1 il a essayé de 2
pour se lier un petit peu froid et de
défendre un petit peu et
en tout cas j'aime bien j'aime bien la
conception ce qu'il a fait un des trois
d'halo 3 s'intéresse
pas qu'on a bien s'ils prennent quand il
a moins de temps à la pendule mai
avec souvent choisi tous les deux de
prendre les blancs parce que humainement
alors peut-être que pour le redis on
voit que le redis la jauge qu'on laisse
elle dit égal
mais la position elle est plus agréable
du côté du côté des blancs clairement
humainement parlant après ce sont des
joueurs d' extrêmement bon niveau qui
arrive des fois à faire les
équilibristes même dans les positions
qui visuellement ne sont pas si facile
que ça il arrive à jouer avec un roi au
centre comme c'est le cas pour 1 ça me
chante landes ici bon tout est possible
encore un même parti perd intéressante
en tout cas
et
moi j'aime beaucoup les blancs dans
cette position là où cela est bien
attaquer c'est logique
mais qu'est-ce qu'on continue le petit
tour des échiquiers parce qu'on n'a pas
vu tout le monde aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on va se faire plaisir à ce que tu as
vu d'autres petites choses sympas
tu sais que moi je suis ultra fan alan
alda mai
ah oui mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
choses qui sont pas rigolo temps on peut
aller vite voir grand des lieux content
car yakine parce que ça c'est vraiment
pas rigolo et il faut qu'on aille aussi
voir les positions sèche mais l'aca
palais rigolote du tout du tout du tout
défense russe
je pense que deux joueurs vont bientôt
signer là nul voilà c'est pas drôle du
tout ils sont
bas
à y voilà j'avais cette position aussi
mais ces poches à paris un petit bug
brassaï et ç'a paru mais je n'avais pas
les coudées part du coût 85 cavaliere
trois cavaliers f6 et la défense russe
dont parlait souffre et
on voit que cela normal à l'avant deux
réputés réputé hyper solide et je crois
que c'est la cayman quentin
cette partie hop donc je vais vous
laisser voilà la fameuse gamme
manquantes donc je vais vous laisser
avec un petit prague contre contre
magnus peut-être alors il est où il se
cache voilà en tout cas défense russe
donc réputés hyper solide car iachini
allez je vais jouer hyper solide et si
grande et lucé envie de venir me
chercher je le contre est donc cavalier
prendre cinq des six cavaliers f3
c'est l'idée de récupérer le pion cavale
et ses 3 c'est une vraie montre assez
ambitieuse puisque on veut faire
cavalier prend pions prend sortir ce fou
sortir cette dame et joue avec le grand
roque si l'adversaire jungle petit parce
que c'est pas forcé on sera dans
l'hérault qu'opposer et ça peu déglingué
salut michel
voilà la limite c'est à toi salut qu en
scène aussi et
du coup on va te montrer ça à prague ce
show il n'y a rien de fait en fait un
beau partout et pour marquant andry
maori dit on peut te répondre déjà que
c'était une partie une ouverture assez
bizarre une hollandaise variant de
bizarre avec des pions pendant blanc
500d pas hyper bon et il ya eu la petite
surprise pour double of qui ne s'est pas
présenté à cause bas du fait qu'il était
qu'à contacter que les autres joueurs et
a demandé qu'il est le masque et du coup
il a refusé et il n'est pas venu jouer
donc là on est en train de vie tu fais
reprendre la partie grand des lieux ce
qui est une une petrov une défense russe
avec une grosse surprise puisque cas et
17 donc on pouvait jouer avec fouet f4
ou faut 3 les deux sont jouables pas de
souci là dessus et là moi je connais le
ku'damm des deux touffes grand roque
puis on peut envoyer h4 et ça rigole et
dames détroit a été jouée
entre nouveauté pour moi bah je sais pas
ça existe peut-être ça existe mais en
des lieux ce ne sont pas de nulle part
mais vous voyez ça bloque le fouet fin
et puis bon surtout il ya des coups
candidats à cavalier 5 et cavaliers c5
j'imagine que sur cavaliers un saint il
regardait c'est tout bête ça n'empêche
quand même prise puis on prend et d'un
b5 et chaque les petits classiques avec
l'option 1 5 qui est perdu
est un pion et du cook avait laissé ça
va partir c'est le coup classique n'est
pas tant donc du coup y'a rien de neuf
fou prend qui on prend d'un prendre et 8
vous prendrez 8 jusque là je sais pas ce
qu'il ya de de 6,9 que cela fout sekkat
ok c'est peut-être légèrement plus
facile à jouer côté blanche que le foot
case noire est vraiment pas terrible
petit rock gros rock ouais bon il valait
ans et fils un jour le flou ce gaz ne
peut être qu'un tour 8 d'accor tour un
tour prend un tour prend un fou 17 parce
qu'il ya mat du couloir
hkd d'accord 3 et fuite
je sens que ça va faire une belle nul
non
non voilà bon ben
on vous annonce qu'il est probable qu'on
aille pas souvent avec souffre regarder
cette partie salut à toi parce touche et
ouais franchement elle est par ego lot
et parigot lot cette partie stouff c'est
pas notre style mais au-delà de ça on a
envie de vous présenter tout le monde
mais la grande et lieu s'il a joué il a
choisi une variante pour ne pas perdre 1
déjà on peut le dire comme ça ok c'est
une position de tête à deux résultats
mais franchement c'est pas très
épanouissant banque et vous allez voir
quelqu'un d'autre en fait
c'est un combat difficile il ay là il a
eu à l'instar un petit peu un petit peu
difficile avec pas mal de défaites au
début c'est sûr et je pense qu'il a
trouvé le bon client pour faire le mieux
rapide parce que le carré qui n'est
toujours aucun je pense pour ce genre de
deux il ya soit et que j'ai j'ai peu de
respect pour qu'avec né à ce niveau là
franchement
c'est un excellent excellent joueur il
ya il a démontré que bien sûr il
sait c'est un monstre mais
non mais aussi qu'il est tellement bien
préparé je trouve que bain dès qu'ils
allaient noir et considère que c'est
bien de faire nul quoi ce qui est pas
faux seins
c'est même très vrai mais il joue pas
assez quoi ouais je suis d'accord avec
toi j'ai bien compris le sens de ta
remarque et c'est vrai que c'est un
pelage à ce niveau là et là on a un
début londe qui n'a pas avancé c'est ça
c'est ça l'histoire qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire là non ils sont pas
que cela soit possible
oui voila je comprenais pas mais ça met
un petit peu de temps là bizarrement à
ceux à se remettre alors regardez début
de l'ombre du grand classique pour vous
et sur ce début de londres il a joué
avec g6
directement
et sursee cap sartre ansar transposerait
dans des bus grenelle
donc 3 on va mettre le système en place
shenouda
fou g7 a été jouée foods du classique
quand même petit rock keim et des deux
mise en place du système ces cinq ces
trois baies six cavaliers 5 que l'on
voit souvent et là on va être dans des
schémas d'attac un peu baril avec
sur terre et 17 h 4
une sorte de blocus au centre et le
cavalier
exact
c'est rigolo c'est rigolo franchement et
du coup la réaction assez intéressante
gaye nat à calais la mise en place par
duda
réaction centrale à mettre en place très
vite cavaliers prend fou prendre et
cavaliers c6 pour enlever des pièces
d'attac au blanc vous prend au roi prend
à chaque essai un schéma qu'on voit
beaucoup dans la dronne fait lille a
ramené sa d'amendés 6 pour venir tenir
les cases et sans doute à terme mettre
un petit e 5 pourquoi pas en place et l
adam se va jouer le rôle du fou en règle
générale c'est à dire à venir sur l'a46
à
regarder le comme ça aussi
arrivé j'étais je me suis dit je vais
lui piquer son idée parce que je suis
sûr qu'il va nous en parler c'est pur
c'est balla lô la connaissez
le en fait sur damas où il aurait
regardée intensément sur la gauche sur
l'ale d'âme et avec des pensées coquines
à l'est le roi voilà voilà ce qui nous
aurait et j'aurais et aurait fixé la
casa 6 avec ma tête voilà
voilà pourquoi vous voyez il y a une
idée de deux rangées de transfert de la
dame sur sur la rangée c'est pas que
damas cap pour damas quatre ça permet
aussi un grand qui éventuel pour les
blonds savait pas dire qu'on va le faire
mais on a cette souplesse là
il ya plusieurs plusieurs idées puis un
petit pressing qui ce qui se crée voilà
bon ok pour l'instant et sait pas encore
grand-chose cette position mais c'est
une partie qui va être assez
intéressante quand même à suivre sous
web en fait les deux joueurs
bon je pense que les deux joueurs ou un
coeur de séminaires partie hindoue da il
est toujours comme ça c'est un joueur
qui aime bien le trike et carole labelle
a perdu hier avec un tour b 6 qui était
pas si vous avez vu un bourrelet ce qui
pour le chat est une énorme gaffe hier
de caravanes à
leur cours baisser se permettre en b 6 à
steve wallace et ça c'est assez rare de
voir des choses comme ça oui tout à fait
et du coup je pense qu'il avoir à coeur
de se refaire et d'essayer de deux
marques et de manquer donc donc je pense
que la partie va s'animer je pense que
via vers l'animation
alors je regarde en même temps ci et
d'autres
c'est un petit tour salut au fait
plaisir de devoir
mais qu
importe c'est la dernière que l'on doit
voir comme ça on aura fini autour des
échiquiers mais on reviendra assurément
sur partie de duda parce qu'elle va être
beaucoup plus passionnante que la partie
car yaqing rang des lieux ski qui paraît
beaucoup plus plate là on est
sur des problèmes sur les rois
actuellement le roi qui n'a pas encore
défini il s est un roi souple ici qu'on
a eu un
c'est toi qui aime bien faire des
cabanes 1
aussi ce taux film semblant donc
il est capable de refaire un coup de la
cabane aujourd'hui quoi vraiment à
chaque fois à chaque fois il n'a pas dit
qu'il allait rockets quelque part donc
en fait dans les positions aiguë où on
commence à attaquer un roi nous avoir le
roi souple bah c'est hyper intéressant
il peut petit roquet grand roque et ou
rester au milieu voilà donc c'est
vraiment intéressant allez on file
chez richard rapporte et le shaq
mamediarov donc du coup richard rapporta
ici les blancs
et
tuba on va vous les mettre à l'écran
déjà et voilà en milliards off qui tire
la tronche mais pourtant il ya une
position tout à fait tout à fait correct
sans doute qu'il ya pas de
bizarre mais ça veut pas
pas le faire
si facile que ça
ok du coup alors comment on est arrivé
là ça nous intéresse de voir un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé donc une
sicilienne ouverte
dit des deux cavaliers et oui alors
pratique personnelle avec les noirs je
joue très fréquemment ce genre de début
et a3 existe à trois ça évite tous les
fous b4 et un des jeux les plus
classiques c'est de transposer un peu
denses et sienne canaille man of la avec
dams et 7 à 6 et je vois que m'améliorer
fils à jouer sera intéressant j'ai déjà
regardé des cinq
puisque le coût à 3 et un petit peu lent
et dans la sicilienne en règle générale
bain mamediarov nous à nous annonce ici
qu'il va vouloir profiter du centre pas
base à base de d5
il le fait directement donc c'est assez
logique
eux des cavaliers des pour commencent à
échanger
cavaliers prend des avec l'idée de
reprendre la dame comme celle là jamais
de pions de piau isolé cavaliers
français si ce
bon
méprendre
ouais mais prend celle ci s'est
peut-être jouable aussi quoi
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que des proches de
madame
dame g4 peut-être c'est ça
n'arrive pas
j'ai quatre ou cinq dames g3 petite
pression
ok mais dans le français 6 mais c'est
tout à fait jouable évidemment fouet
trois fous 17 dam des deux
pensées pas jusque là très rigolo
d'autant plus que bon vous semble le bon
coup avec son fouet fuite qui demande à
sortir et le mien ans et 5 pour les
échanger contre le fouet trois grands
que [ __ ] trois dames 33 que c'est que
tu vois juste avant avant le camp rock
et ben laden c6
contrôle du fonds ai fait que si je sors
mon goût souvent avant il y avait un
point de vue et du coup on fait des lois
ont pas envie de perdre leur temps à
défendre l'option s'en tire le coup
franc le rhodes et du coup ça plus ou
moins forcé des blancs à à prendre la
décision de faire le grand roque et du
coup ça ça va faire à faire de même et
des remords qui elle vient aussi attaqué
les joueurs qui ont vraiment joué pour
pour
tour c'est 8 alors là est ce que fout
des trois n'était pas jouable
ce que je vois qu'il a joué ses trois
pour tout vous dire richard rapporte
alors que là naturellement j'ai envie de
jouer food étroit avec l'idée que si
maintenant je perds g2g ce à quoi je
suis étonné qu'il ait joué ses trois
puisque ces trois ça paraît beaucoup
plus moche si vous voulez
j'aime pas trop le laisser les troubles
s'étaient sont pas si grave mais c'est
étonnant
ça paraît beaucoup plus naturelle à
fouday 3
je comprends pas
ce que jusque là tout était vraiment
logique et là on s'attend comme un fou
détroit
je regarde comment pourrait être
way à d'un projet de dames des 5 c'est
ça
on va on voit les fous des trois dames
projet de
tour g1 serait arrivé peut-être
ouais mais en fait j'ai fou et
4g fou et quatre genevois
il ya encore d'alger cadre mais bon
on voit que le food et s'est décoincé
donc ne peut pas fou détroit
complètement jouable complètement
jouable foulée 3 même plus naturel que
que c'est trop on va dire
manqué ses trois ses fins et voilà c'est
des trous mais ils sont pas exploitables
par l'adversaire
donc c'est quand même ça reste ça reste
jouable et sur dame c5 qui est
finalement une sorte de propositions nul
1 puisqu'après d'un procès cinq tours
france et 5 c'est vraiment très
égalisant ben richards apporte à faire
le a fait le choix de jouer cette
position
g6
il fallait bien défendre de purger sept
fous des trois maintenant
x 4 a été jouée par par médias off et
tours d2 1 b 5
même pour moi ça rejoint un petit peu ce
qu'on disait dans la partie précédente
de duda stouff c'est que je
potentiellement je garde la souplesse de
mon droit en 8 qui ne peut pas là tout
de suite se faire attaquer pour ne pas
donner l'adresse de mon doigt
vraiment en même temps j'ai craché j'ai
quand même envie de le jouer mais
peut-être j'aurais g5 tu vois alors que
si j'avais refait mon petit rock c'était
plus risqués tout ça peut-être
un
peu
ouais en tout cas je suis toujours pas
alors j'ai vu un comme tout le monde que
la jauge
n'avait pas bondi sur le c3 proposé par
richard à porte mais j'ai toujours du
mal si on y revient
si on revient dessus tout femme a joué
ses trois dans cette position est plus
en plus la partie en train de nous
donner raison puisque tu m'as l'air du
même avis souffre c'est vrai que c'est
bizarre enfin maintenant il ya un trou
alors que si j'avais joué food et 3
on a vu que d'un projet 2 finalement
n'était pas jouable
ça me paraît si vous voulez moins facile
de percer parce que quand mes pions sont
ces 3 à 3 il ya une grosse percée en b 4
qui n'est pas existantes simon pions et
en c2 enfin je peux jouer comme 1,5 b5
bi 4 mai
alors peut-être de saison c'est faire
évidemment ce n'est que sur b3 lui
aurait coupé sa
non j'ai pas trouvé pour tout vous dire
pourquoi il avait joué je pense que les
deux en fait été jouable mais
naturellement humainement alors pourtant
richard laporte il est humain aussi mais
c'est un hyper talent et c'est vrai que
j'aimerais bien qu'il commente avec nous
ce c3
avec dams et trois
dames cinq dames g3 est fou b52 stouff
et sur un projet cet état je prends des
je laisse ma tour
à voir
hors france que mangent les deux tours
ouais
on peut le montrer non mais en fait si
je fais ça stouff tu arrives
tu voulais même carotter souffre a qu'un
quidam ces deux noms mais on peut dire
fou des trois c'était jouable 1 dames
ces cinq
sets 3
6 7 3 et
hockey monte à son aide les deux les
deux sont jouables on voit bien bon rien
tout neuf mais je commence à aimer la
position de média of en fait ça paraît
plus lisible un petit peu avec avec les
noirs
coop
et
j'ai demandé d' actualiser la position
parce que
alors est ce que
nos rapports n'a pas joué donc on est
bien dans cette position b5 et il n'y a
pas une nouveauté ok mais bon on va
pouvoir continuer notre petit tour c'est
peut-être le moment d'aller voir nos
petits notre petit frenchy parce qu'on a
été on a été faire toutes les parties du
ha et je vous propose en direct la
partie du
petit frenchy que je voulais c'est que
le mix des calmes comme ça on va partir
un petit peu partout au niveau des
calmes
et donc là eh bien on voit que
ça va quand même mieux peut-être pour
pour marc-andré on va voir un petit peu
les en étant d'accord les temps ont été
réactualisés là et
du coup c'est toujours un petit peu la
même chose alors on va voir on était
nous dans cette position là après la
séquence et des 4e des cas donc il a
créé les pions pendant ça on avait bien
vu
je peux être que le pion des caps
passera jamais en rouge donc pions
s'écarter des cats faibles et forts
contrôle du centre mes faiblesses
potentielles cavalier e 4 un coup que
j'aimais beaucoup de la part de marc
andry pour essayer de mettre la pression
sur les pions faibles et forts en même
temps dame ces deux cas et c6 son
adversaire il joue simple pour
verrouiller ses pions centre au
monde un v6 il rajoute de la pression
est là cavalia 3 a été jouée
jeu qu'à et ses trois devaient être
difficile difficile à jouer
et k3 du coup on va pouvoir jouer à
terme pour peut-être tourbe et un
cavalier bekaert a été jouée d'un b 3
bon alors ça a l'air d'être une place
oui oui c'est ça en fait
ma connerie là il a mis ses pièces vers
l'avant très bien mais qu'est ce que je
fais maintenant à ce que le centre de
l'adversaire risque de le gêner ya des
histoires caraïbes et cinq dans cette
position
ces cinq bien sûr là là il ya une grosse
menace
ça gagne la partie est donc
là déjà il a trouvé un coup
bref aussi sa faute au regard d un
cavalier b5 des cinq ça commençait à
devenir concret
pas facile déjà cette position je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez dans le chat
mais honnêtement
franchement je trouve que la position
allait elle est dure
ouais je me
franchement
quand simone j'ai un peu de mal à jouer
la position et menouar ouais parce que
même par exemple vous aussi
d'ailleurs il ya eu foule six cavaliers
mais cinq
parties
ok c'était la gamme pro b 5e
du coup on a vu la jauge avait pris un
coup sur la tête
[Musique]
non apparemment très faiblement macaques
dans le chat qui me dit que
mon temps faiblement 1 en tentant
faiblement et pourtant si je regarde et
ben je t'ai mis beaucoup plus fort tout
à l'heure on traîne il n'y a plus la
remarque et je peux regarder
j'espère que c'est
assez efficace tout ce que je fais et je
te laisse du coup avec la partie de de
marque andrietti ou un gros chat six
mois et ça va mieux si c'est toujours
alors donc d'abord témoin quand on
regarde d'où il ya eu il ya eu foule et
six cavaliers b5 donc là ce qu'il faut
regarder déjà je pense c'est d'emprunter
5 1 c'est mieux donc en fait
ouais je sais pas jusqu'où
augmenter ces sales histoires
allaient tac
voilà un chef j'ai essayé d'augmenter
stefano au maximum 1 je peux c'est un
peu mieux il me semble donc c'est pas
non plus
incroyables apparemment mais
je fais mon maximum je trouve pour pour
contentant de bien puisque moi j'entends
très bien se trouve donc vous avez bien
raison de nous dire pour votre
expérience
c'est mieux ça va c'est bien
vrai
tableau on disait que dans des sacs
c'est le point guard parce qu en fait à
part après tu en prends des 5 je vois
pas trop ce qu'on pourrait faire avec et
non parce que le cavaly temps prise en
d4
et c'est pour revenir en c6
sais pas trop c'était vraiment utile
même gamme allait cesser dès 5 ans c'est
parce qu'ils avaient encore du cavalier
à 5 tout ça mais ça m'a l'air vraiment
non j'aime bien ce que tu dis souvent
lensois prennent en pro b 5 puis on
prend fou prend b3 prend b3 on a une
sorte de consolidation à terme avec
mandanda et d5 d'abord et si derrière
sans doute
c'est juste le problème de sur assiette
qu'il faudra régler qui me
et puis j'ai aussi fou est aussi
bon en fait je comptais je te gêne est
si tu veux avec cavaliers des cinq dans
cette position j'aurais préféré attendre
pour le jouer ok imaginons je joue tout
de suite
vous et 4,6
je trouvais cette flèche mais
c'est à dire
'ok up a eu l'idée de 6
pouces et 4 6 qui joue x 3 je peux faire
tours fc 8
c'est l'air d'aller ah oui je menace
aussi qu'avec des petits des oueds et
des choses à terme un cahier ces trois
là deux places honda fou c4
mais je me pose la question si tu veux
de loin c'est ce qu'a dû voir nguyen ici
a dû se dire qu'ils ont à sète il va
tomber
c'est pas si facile en fait de jouer un
bon coup peut-être tour à 3 mais yahia
les tours fc 8 qui soit un peu pénible à
gérer après c'est fou ces quatre là fous
ces cas toujours
donc tour à 3 c'est pas un coût ridicule
là
comment on fait avec baignoire pour
gérer cela
le pion à celle ci je te le mange bien
ouais c'est ça
paraît
paraît pas si facile à gérer quand même
notre histoire
sur k et ses 3 oui je peux jouer dans ce
genre de position
qu'a eue ces trois français trois quais
prend c'est trop fou sekkat échec
et après à terme tour un
non c'est pas si clair quand même hein
on comprend de façon si le grand maître
à jouer cette position avec cavaliers b5
ce qu'ils y croyaient
est-ce que par défaut de toute façon
j'ai un vrai autre coup
je peux jouer qu'à et c6 dans cette
position
c'est chaud à mes os 10 sam alarmant du
bricolage oui mes dessins
en fait j'ai une petite
ya toujours stouff le pion à f2 qui aura
l'air bon du coup je me dis que est il
fou de derrière
voyez hein donc c'est pour ça que des
cinq fours chaîne n'est pas vraiment une
fourchette à cause du pion aux lèvres de
en l'air
voilà
donc attention quand même pour
l'adversaire c'est pas si simple
non vraiment pas si simple on le voit on
s'en rend compte
du coup j'ai un petit peu
un petit peu gêné c'est pas si facile de
prendre la décision avec les noirs
mesdames promet 5 c'est peut-être pas
s'ils vont aux truffes
en tout cas on n'a pas vu comment gèrent
les deux choses tadam trombe et 500
prend b5 on n'a pas vu comment gères
après fou prend b3 promet 3 et la menace
poussé quatre qui est quand même très
pénible
et l'histoire du pion à bord je joue à 5
directement mais je crois pas
il y avait prend un fou ces quatre noms
la paire de fouet tofu trop forte donc
finalement j'ai pas envie de
me prendre ou alors on a peut-être
quelque chose que l'on n'a pas vu mais
et puis ça me disais bien mais après
après réflexion n'a pas réussir à gérer
cette position à cause du doublement des
tours sur un fonds peut avoir une bonne
lecture sur les pions
et du coup ben au final se trouve je
suis plutôt pour faire ce qu'on a appelé
du bricolage aka et c6
parce que là dans cette position je
menacerait entre guillemets un petit
peut-être à 6
ou simplement autour des 8 ouais je joue
contre les pions contre les pions
pendante de toute façon est ce que c'est
pas ça un petit peu depuis le départ
c'est à dire m'ont dit que c'est du
bricolage parce que la position de marc
andré est un peu bizarroïdes par contre
je trouve qu'ils la jouent vraiment bien
c'est à dire qu'il a été très dynamique
souffre depuis le départ marque andry
donc il est peut-être en train de
revenir un peu dans la partie
ouais on va voir un peu sa promesse a
déjà joué moi je pense ça va être joué
mais on n'a pas trouvé on n'a pas trouvé
la suite au début je pensais que c'était
un très bon coup
mais moi je pense que c'est intéressant
et des 5e 6e place est si dense ou
france
3 trucs contraire
mais je pense que vraiment s'il joue pas
ça il va vraiment être mais voilà aussi
ok c'est se situe pas dans la loi enfin
un peu non tu veux pas tu veux pas salir
d'hockey c'est pour ça qu'à et d5 est
fort simple idée on a dit toi trois là
c'est quand même pas si facile parce que
mon tour s'est vite j'ai poussé quatre
c'est ça tu bloques avec fous ces quatre
que tu as dit du coup on pourra pas
enlever facilement sous c4
ou alors tour ses huit fous ces 4 6 avec
l'idée qu à l es6 toof
et bon tour enfin c'est beaucoup de
c'est loin c'est pas facile à faire
la chasse est un way lâchés à 7 puis
avoir bessette en l'air c'est vraiment
dur
peut-être un peut-être évidemment mais
c'est
c'est franchement pas si facile que ça
cavale et des six son premier propose
michel
cavalli des 600 premiers on va voir ça
t'as quand tout premier cas et des six
donc là je vois pas trop michel calvet 5
ya menace dame prend bec atteint donc ça
doit être peut-être après d'un premier 5
puis en pro b 5 fu prend puis on prend
et cavaliers des six là
mais il faut toujours laisser de dettes
moi je pense dans ce cas là que je veux
jouer tour à quatre mêmes idées mais je
tape le cavalier ici cette fois
cavalier des cinq du coup il n'y a pas
le choix
là j'ai déjà les fous ces cadres de
stouff qui sont toujours d'actualité
oui sur quelle est pressée car je
voulais faire p prend faut que je fasse
attention peut-être à club et si ce
n'est toujours pas facile cette position
parce que là encore j'ai tours 1
je vais tourner plutôt un michel
et du coup je tapage tapas est
peut-être tour ses huit
voiliers je pense l'idée avec tour ces
deux
et là je comptais jouer food et 3 et sur
food et 3 jeux ne percevoir peut-être de
peut-être cavaliers c3
t'imagines à calculer stouff c'est
vraiment sur le fil pour les noirs
franchement c'est dire si c'est ça la
saillie terreur quoi tout cela s'il faut
qu'ils voient tout ça en tout cas
il doit sentir même
ainsi qu en fait moi je vais arriver
noir j'avais bien envie de se retrouver
son âme promet 5 pour le côté changement
de position parce que la position de
pelé pas trop mais au final ben j'ai pas
trouvé la réfute de cas et c6 qui
semblait moins logique au départ
mais
à la voir
ou revoir
et b5 adam prend b5 vient d'être jouée
sous x là
j'ai senti ce que j'avais vu là
donc il a joué dans promesse un qui n'a
pas joué et c'est ici alors on peut
regarder pour une fois je vous rappelle
qu'on fait des commentaires sans ordi et
parce qu'on préfère avec souffre là je
vais rajouter pour une fois la variante
et du coup sûr qu'à et b5 je veux juste
voir qu'à et c6
il faudrait que ça que ça marche
c'est d'enlever vraiment trop mais
aujourd'hui c'est léger mais ils
viennent
ils voudraient et voudra pas
türk a et b saint qui veut pas me
remettre
ils jouent pas
ce qui fâche et non elle veut pas me
lâcher un petit qui comme ça un petit
refresh total
vous aussi si les tours à b1 c'était mon
coup d'accord
kébé 5 et 10 bien dans le premier cinq
nécessité le deuxième coup était jouable
mais on en reste avec les mêmes
problèmes et d'un promet 5 c'est une
opportunité est temps qu'on a on avait
vu ex toof tout ça
les cadets 5
on a déjà par ahmed cette position nous
on à paris à
les regarder est intéressante
d'ordinateurs d'ailleurs pas ce qu'ils
disent est fou c'est 4 6 et après tout
ces 86 et mayotte h 4 et je trouvais
intéressant h4 parce qu'en fait ce
qu'ils voudraient faire c'est essayer
d'échanger les cavaliers donc avec
avaler g5 et une fois que le cavalier
disparaîtrait
la position là je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup de problèmes en fait pour les
noirs on est en train de voir on va
enlever les bénévoles on a regardé un
peu un petit plaisir mais que ce soit
toi 3 et 3,5 c'est déjà un problème
plus facile de voir que h 4 kg 5 je
pense règles idée sympa mais même toit
troyes et tours à cinq qui sont des
coups aussi claudie proposé qu'on avait
vu précédemment c'est vraiment simple et
je trouve que les noirs vont devoir
s'employer pour trouver là la bonne
solution dans cette dans cette position
et on a vu que mon
le joueur avec les
aveugles et blanc un petit peu déconné
dans cette position parce que sur
cavaliers mais 5 il a offert une
possibilité dynamique
alors que leur dis lui annoncer un
avantage de deux pions après tour à b1
parce que les pièces noires était pas si
bien placé près de deux pions c'est un
petit peu exagéré mais on avait vu avec
sauf que c'était vraiment beaucoup plus
agréable donc c'est un petit peu un
petit peu dommage
en tout cas en tout cas on voit bien que
c'est pas si facile pas si facile pour
mes
moins dur ok ouais je suis d'accord avec
toi mais position sans doute à deux
résultats comme je vois pas marc andré
gagné aujourd'hui règles et noir
d'entraînement parce que les blancs si
vous voulez vous un petit pressing il
peut faire nul il a des chances réelles
de nul mais quand même la position
blanche s'avère plus facile à jouer pour
son adversaire
se trouvait ce qu'on repart voir magnus
on repart voir quelqu'un
qu'est ce qui te casses qui tirait pas
ce que ton petit prague
tu as envie d'aller le voir je pense non
non je propose un tel talent chose temps
à autre chose avant que je te propose
sur la page de pub déjà une page de pub
mais alors là c'est à coeur non mais
dans le dans le shaq fu s'exciter un
petit peu las to be vous mettre de la
pub tout toute la journée
il en fait le but du jeu c'est de nier
ce qui vient d'arriver sur le chat ça va
pas + j'ai dit pourquoi tu es ouais t'as
vu jc ben voilà et ouais c'est ça êtes
vous savez vous savez on est on à un
contre un en fait un process com et
twitch on est obligé de faire une passe
de clips de sept minutes chaque heure
donc on n'a pas de choix en fait masser
ça quand mon corps c'est des gros chêne
tous face c'est normal il faut il faut
sinon faut aller sur la chaîne de
souffle si vous voulez avoir moins de
pub ça qu'on va dire maintenant stouff
voilà donc on a nos chaînes aussi perso
n'hésitait pas pendant les pubs aller
les voir ça nous fera un grand plaisir
de vous retrouver de temps en temps sur
sur nos chaînes perçoit aussi emma du
court je suis je vais envoyer la pub
alors il souffre la chaîne la scène de
kevin et en vue qui ont envie de la
connaître
est ce que
est ce que je mets un petit générique la
veille le tata steel où on repart pour
la pour la salle pour la salle qu'est ce
que tu veux stouff
aller à les gens vont et maintenant j'en
vois une petite vidéo alors dans ce cas
là allez faites vous plaisir la vidéo
avec tous les joueurs et on vous dit à
tout de suite
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
pas
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien après et coucou les amis on est
reparti avec stouff à eelv a fait une
petite blague à la pause il s'est mis
mi-août et du coup je pensais qu'on
avait un souci technique sur le son est
en fait voilà bah il m'a fait le coup il
m'a fait le coup de se mettre en route
et moi c'était déjà des sueurs froides
mais c'est bon c'est bon on est là ça
nous fait plaisir et st j sais d'eux
qu'ils voulaient ou jc tout comme on
veut qu'ils voulaient qu'on aille voir
caruana stouff juste qu'on peut dire
c'est que là on était sur la partie de
marc andré maori 10,1 pour pour le
moment stéphane et je suis assez étonné
de tours c'est un tour ces deux qui a
été jouée par par le joueur tchèque
bon parce que je pensais qu'il fallait
vraiment mettre là la pression champions
à 7
mai après
4 mais il est vrai qu'il a le tour c'est
ben je vais tour c'est vrai je comprends
pas ce qu'il est en train de faire mais
bon après je préfère toujours la
position blanche avec le pipe racing
l'équipe racing
et on va pouvoir aller de notre côté sur
sur les partis
du haut on va partir dans le a et
là ça s'excite un petit peu du côté de
m'hamed et
de richard rapporte donc on a vraiment
une partie dans le style des deux
joueurs maintenant où là on arrive au
bon moment ça s'excite est ce qu'on va
pouvoir aller on avait promis j7 où on
va aller de faire plaisir on avait dit
qu'on allait voir la partie caruana
donc on revient on s'était arrêté tout
après damas quatre et on avait dit qu'il
ya des il ya des petits trucs qu'aucun
là qui allait arriver éventuellement
avec du tama caton h4 donc c'était
possible est ce qu'on disait aussi c'est
que le roi en plein milieu de
l'échiquier mais il est souple donc ça
nous faisait pas peur ok
exactement et
tu vois ce toof caruana et il aurait eu
peur contre toiture avec tes histoires
de damages 4 c'est pour ça qu'il a fait
c'est prend des voix l'a fait c'est
prendre
exactement il veut pas devoir tourner
damage 4 il connaît et connaît aussi en
christophe donc voilà il en veut pas ok
c'est assez logique ce qu'il a fait
cavalier enfin c'est un coup pour
ramener le cavalier à la fête on a le
droit de faire des manoeuvres de
cavaliers particulièrement conte et
structures sont figés et là c'est vrai
que le coussin qu'on craque pas
nécessairement parce que ça ferait un
pion isolé quand même ce pas c'est pas
dans le sens du jeu et un joli g5 j'ai
envie de dire dans l'idée de protéger le
roi ça ça se comprend par contre il est
évident qu'après on a agi ce qui arrive
est bonne séquence évidemment de jan
christoph duda qui a attaqué le fou pour
recycler son guerrier et le petit à chis
intermédiaire
pour que le roi soit toujours mal c'est
à dire que j'ai pas gagner tout de suite
attaqué ouvrir le roi noir mais sur le
long terme non le roi noir est plus
fragile que laurent blanc même si
j'aimerais encore dit où j'allais jorane
honda manger cette même des fois un mode
du couloir
tous voient déjà le match du couloir et
est-ce que son pronostic sera bon
ça promet ça promet
dame b 3 et oui oui et c'est vrai qu'il
y en a qui doivent se demander où on en
est un petit peu d'aidé des soldes
donc du coup passe tout fait en train de
oued de me reprendre un petit à petit et
stouff baup
c'est énorme pour moi c'est énorme on
peut mieux quoi alors ouais enfin
c'est le premier
donc tu sais je viendrai avec grand
plaisir
sur ta chaine régler mes comptes mais il
va falloir que je bosse un petit peu
sous parce que c'est pas comme si ça
m'était arrivé grandement je ne sais pas
du tout comment ça marche comme ça tu
fais mais
j'ai jusque là j'ai jamais eu besoin
avec toi de savoir enfin
la bonne c'est tout ce que j'ai à faire
c'est tout ce que j'ai à faire
ok non mais c'est pas ces taux sont je
savais que toi sont généralement payés
s'est jamais un problème tu vois non les
choses sont assez facilité pour ce qui
est ce qu'ils veulent veulent payer mais
ça sera un vrai qu'un grand plaisir j'ai
vraiment envie de m'abonner à la chaîne
de deux touffes parce que ben ouais on
s'amuse bien échangé puis bah vous savez
un je découvre un peu twitch depuis
septembre donc je progresse pas à pas
dirons nous
donc il ya eu un e 6 dans cette partie
pour protéger des cinq tours d un tour d
un mais il veut vraiment par ok jan
christoph duda donc il joue tour d un
pour nous faire mentir après le roi des
droits c'est un tu vas voir ça n'a pas
manqué en plus c'est un peu à la mode à
cette manoeuvre oui c'est pas mal de
petits coups notamment sait plus qui
c'est qui avait joué au paris donc avec
le roi 17
dans une loge quel point c'était il ya
pas mal de tournois où je vois des rois
des deux resserrent un avis aussi romain
alors qu'il y avait même qui avait
commenté un
facebook j'avais vu il avait bien un
truc comme quoi les temps par la ligue
suisse je crois il y avait eu une grande
sicilienne il y avait eu droit les
droits siens
quand tu l'as et je le vends
régulièrement ce genre de de manoeuvre
pour bien pire aux deux genres rock je
connais pas quoi ouais ouais c'est
plutôt sympa après le coup de la cabane
la hyène cruz ian christophe duda nous
fait le rock le grand roque en trois
coups quand tu peux le faire en un coup
voilà il nous apprend des trucs m
christophe à chaque partie
hier tandis que le chat fatigue commence
à raconter un peu n'importe quoi sur une
certaine mauvaise foi de ma part c'est
vraiment bien bien étonnant grosse
fatigue du chat
voilà c'est normal voilà au bout de
quelques heures de réflexion intense le
chat fatigue voilà voilà ce que ce que
je retiens
et je dis
ah ben si si on avait vu qu'elle était
mon seul surtout que là ça s'est un peu
éteint
du coup là ils sont en train de se
[ __ ] sur la tronche on peut le dire
comme ça et on va aller voir
en fait c'est hyper intéressant pour les
joueurs amateurs cette position
particulièrement lé les plus faibles
parce qu'on voit typiquement ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est la course l
attaque et là c'est hyper intéressant
parce que l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir avec
les leviers de pions les colonnes pour
aller sanctionner le roi adverse et ce
qui est marrant c'est que des fois on
voit dans les parties de haut niveau que
ça contrôle avant d'attaquer là il n'y a
pas du tout de contrôler ses prises de
risque total des deux joueurs et on a la
jauge donc on voit que c'est assez
équilibré alors c'est une position de
folie elle est cinglé cette position et
c était intéressant a gardé
pas mal c'est que cela fait noir de
jouer et après les français 3 eh ben je
pense que l'idée de rapporter de fer h6
et je te le dis je n'arrive pas tort sur
l'échec
après bon c'est trois à six c'est
prendre des échecs croire qu'en d2 -
vont apprendre les deux il ya plus des
chèques pour les noirs et comment tu
rentres
alors la question c'est
pour mamediarov qu'est-ce que joue
alors le fameux g5 se transforme en pas
fameux g5 ici hein parce que bien sûr il
ya une double idée joué par richard à
penly des principales en fait c'est le
maton g7 que stouff a annoncé dans une
autre partie la partie de caruana et
l'idée l'idée secondaire peut-être quand
je prends g6 pour ouvrir et commencé à
casser la chaîne de pions noirs et oui
alors du coup qu'est ce que va faire
m'hamed il y as gh1 qui existent stouff
mais ça a l'air d'être un coup difficile
à jouer quand même à cause de tour age
iii par exemple le coût de l'ascenseur
voilà ça ça damas schiste c'est lui
peut-être même du proche
tout à fait
vrai mais là faut trouver un peu de
défense 1 qu'est ce que parce qu on a vu
la jauge on a vu la jauge il m'avait dit
tu peux pas perdre comme ça non plus
mais qu'est ce qu'il a prévu qu'est ce
qu'il a prévu un de la
wii et je vais aussi montré au chat la
bonne came comme ça on va tous bien
montré
soyons soyons fous et la mamelle il en
train de normalement il y gère en calcul
donc c'est pas possible qu'il soit au
bout du bout c'est vraiment impossible
même
du coup on va regarder la vente de deux
touffes label variante pris ces trois
noms mais en fait à chis il y avait
quand même prise b2 à regarder aussi ce
qu'on a c'est que prises des deux
surprises de deux il fait froid prend
grandes cases de soufre ce que son roi
il est protégé en d2
vois la magnifique et bien sûr le maton
g7 il n'y a pas de bons échec
exact
donc dans cette situation
après à chaque prise est 3 h is prise b2
est là
et là qu'est ce que tu jouais stouff
en fait j'ai
une petite idée on va faire ça et ça
c'est un peu du délire mais
s'avère sympa
tu dis
ouais tour à deux c'est la fin de
variantes roi promet deux pour moi comme
j'ai joué tour b 8 j'ai pas vu d'autres
coups
sûrs roi de il y avait foule b3 que je
trouvais pas clair du tout donc j'ai
décidé moi un d'un point à trois
victoires à deux
c'est un bateau à 7,8 de variantes
c'est mignon comme tout merci à stouff
pour cette petite
dédicace avec le petit coup à chis
franchement ça fait mal mais du coup
qu'est ce qui va faire mamediarov là
dessus
il a joué déjà regardé il a joué à chis
sur les six premiers qui
avaient peut-être pas trop le choix en
fait
en fait pour parer le ashes de stouff il
ya eu le haschich de m'hamed
voilà
on identifie la menace adverse y avait
trop chaud trop chaude
mais on fait dans les rangs composer ce
qu'on appelle un coup de frein
sauf que là le coup de frein il est
dingue parce qu'il a g6 qui est archi en
l'air mais ma merde il se dit baye
agissent en l'air mais toi tu as et 3 à
3 c'est le premier qui mate c'est ultra
chaud
moi je dis que cette partie elle va
faire un nul en fait on la connaît en
fait à un moment ils auront bien joué
les deux joueurs il va y avoir ashes par
exemple baissé et la moye aura baissé
ils vont échanger les dames et faire une
nulle super sympa de combat quoi on la
connaît celle là stouff jeu l'annoncent
jeu l'annoncent
en fait c'est lors d'un et dont il on
va dire
les capacités
de 2 très facilement toutes les défenses
way est une des intuitions de dengue en
plus
parce que la solution est de
londres et merci voilà en fait tu vas
très souvent je pense plus je trouvais
les habituels
excuse moi tout j'étais en train de
regarder la remarque de michel là sur ce
best français troyes et tours prend un
schiste que tu dises excuse moi
mais en fait à ce niveau là
parce qu'ils voient là en fait et
manager un plus trouver une façon de
trouver des perpétuelles plutôt que des
maths en fait ils vont tous très bien
calculé et s'en remet à des problèmes
que
plus haut niveau tellement réussi un
bien étrange que ça a plus pensé par
annuler que vert
webb à son oui c'est clair que
en plus particulièrement dans cette
position ça s'avère de mener un
équilibre et à une simplification non
memish du coup oui
c'est assez logique que ça prenne pas
l'eau complet corps que des foires et
pas le choix je on va peut-être regarder
la vente de michèle riehle disait h
projet
6b prend ses 3 il voulait qu'on regarde
tout reprend à chis et voyez rien
attention me choque tout à tout en l'air
privé de l arganier n'ont
fait que michelle gargar des prises de
la tour mais la prise b2 michel sala
regagné direct roi prend b dames c'est
un tu es obligé un songe aux dames c'est
indirect
roi de là je peux regarder je peux te
régaler avec dame 3d de haut pierre g
dames 3 schiste pour faciliter le calcul
en plus comme je bouge les pièces la vie
et la vie est facile donc en fait tu
avais raison je crois à michel sur mes
procès de quand tu es tout reproche ici
j'avais fait la gaffe prises des deux
non non mais c'est un gars fait pas même
prise des deux gagnent regard doit
prendre des deux il ya dame c1 est d'un
machisme tout gagné en fait
non tu arrives après un michel parce que
j'arrête pas de faire et chaque échec
échec tu as dû croire que ton roi était
tranquille tu as oublié va casser un
peut-être michel tout simplement parce
que la tour ne peut pas sauver dans le
calcul c'est souvent un problème la
dernière pièce qui vient de partir mal
contrôlée à caser maintenant voilà peut
aller là
ouais ben bassaw michel tu as dit c'est
ça j'ai oublié b2 mais même des deux ça
marche pas donc du coup à michel hop ça
arrive on connaît ces histoires de
calcul
mais d'ailleurs
j'ai fait une faute aussi c'est assez
rigolo d'ailleurs michel tient parce que
je suis embêté michel mais du coup
victime d'une image inerte le michel
c'est pas mal il aime bien en plus ce
genre de débat michel parce qu'il adore
le calcul comme thème et chic y un mais
franchement j'ai proposé une bêtise là
donc je vais donc prise b2 on voit que
ça gagne soit on prend 1,6 enfin je
pensais jouer ça ça dames c'est un là en
fait sur one day à food est un qui gagne
puisque sur de food et un après je fais
fou découverte maths mais je disais à
michel en fait dans cette position je
menace à chis des sur eux deux si je te
rends bêtement hashich me faire tourner
avec gf cette
voie là est la dame achi c'est en l'air
du coup il faut toujours faire gaffe
mais sur roues eu deux normalement on
doit prendre un petit peu son temps dans
cette position même si on avait prévu
d'un prend 1,6 on est sauvé par food et
un au même titre que tour ces deux
devaient pas perdre mais fou d un match
en deux coups donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment plus fort en tout cas bravo aux
médias renforçons à chis c'est
franchement sympa on a vu à bab
hélas après à bab
massage ou et richard et il est en train
de réfléchir
donc j'en profite pour celui là
oliech countout oliech très bon ami à
moi m la semaine
est ce qu'il est français oliech
ok il aime beaucoup de riz
bon ok
du coup je suis en train de chercher
parce que qu'on annonce connais un petit
peu tout ça vous savez des titres est
français
depuis basse la deuxième année luke
ovide et là il a pu jouer et là bas leur
matraque ou marseille ben j'ai vu j'ai
juste justement
donc je suis en train de me j'ai vu là
mais j'ai vu la fin et j'ai été regardée
tu vois pour pourvoir un petit peu ce
gros match c'est la jeunesse
marseillaise qui a assuré
bon j'irai voir agir revoir
d'accord pas mal une miellerie
est alors comment ça va comment ça va se
régler cette position est ce que ça va
pas simplifier
facilement
[Musique]
précédé
sur la vente concrètes pour l'instant
c'est quoi à j'ai
baissé
ma glide et surbaissé dame à 3
donc je vais pas le faire
mais jugé f7 pourvoir
trois fois
donc tu prends
sur un
danger si tu fais roy fdjeux pense
quoi la prend 2,6 et si je fais
d'emprunt she was set
laurent louis
vuitton et dame prend 1,6
voyez comme c'est compliqué on va en
voir la jouer si vous voulez pour vous
voyez mais je crois que tu peux te
cacher elle est chaude ces deux-là déjà
un
donc ça
ok çà çà çà
çà
meilleurs accords d'emprunt si c'était
chaud de cette variante je pense
donc ça ne paraît plus logique pour
éviter de 1.6 et c'est là que j'arrêtais
je me trouvais en difficulté j'avais pas
vu que je pouvais carotter le fou
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est vrai
d'ailleurs
c'est à confirmer moi ce que je pense
pas d'ancêtres l'idée c'était de la fin
tu peux pas pouvoir en 17 je pense oui
ouais après ce que je suis droite je
n'ai pas droit de faire sa
ba comme vous voyez comme la tour 2 to
ferrand en l'air je crains pas trop les
perpétuelles quoi c'est plus le
raisonnement qui me permet de jouer un
coup comme roi des six qui est vraiment
hyper bizarre visuellement
en tout cas vous voyez pour richard
rapporte parce que là on bouge les
pièces donc on à prat pas ne mérite par
rapport aux joueurs en bougeant les
pièces c'est et puis on revient en plus
donc si on se trompe donc c'est ça va
c'est facile c'est bien d'être
commentateur par rapport à joueurs à ce
niveau là c'est pas nos pièces on fait
ce qu'on veut on fait ce qu'on veut si
on donne une pièce c'est pas grave
mais ok c'était vraiment intéressant
encore un bon allez on va pas trop bien
faire mais ça mérite et le calcul avec
une position est claire bordélique et il
s'est plutôt le
c4 positionnelle dans les recomposer
c'est à dire plutôt d'aller dans la
baston des fois il ya eu le coup de
frein ashes de mamediarov il ya eu à
prendre et apprend b pour
pour que la position ne souffre pas trop
avec des mets prend 1,3 et maintenant je
joue c4 pour fermer la pause pour
combien de temps ça c'est pas clair on
pourrait
très bien voir à terme des g5 et pour
l'instant tout va et souligné l uds dame
prend 1,6 donc en fait des êtres
vivants 1 mesdames g5 je peux prendre un
jet tu vas faire f 5 peut-être parce que
c'est compliqué aussi prise
je veux manger c'est taper sur f2
j'avais encore une fois qu'ils vont
aussi en deçà près
d'alger sans une part et paraît logique
je prends parce que madame rêve si ces
meubles 6 juin coups de recul bah je
vais me prendre la pression derrière
prise est prise là les deux coups
différents foyers bien fc antibes et
j'aurai une bonne structure
soit je présente mangeant g6 bientôt
sur les franges et 6 on n'a pas peur de
vous rendre et 6
peut pas être au four et au moulin ouais
moi je suis pas grand fan de ce genre de
structure mais il ya des arguments
dynamique de deux touffes qui est de
dire ben ouais mais avec l'hymne je sors
ma tour f8 donc ça c'est une vraie
argumentation
bon j'avoue que j'étais pas à ses fans
de f5 crois j'essais droit g6 mais bon
ok mais deux ans les deux son job mais
vous voyez la position elle va
s'éteindre un mot
sur votre foi qu'ils aient pas aussi
détourage s'était pourtant on était un
peu un annoncé la mode matour et en d2
au
sujet parce que 5 tours 7 c'est ce que
je veux mais je l'avais regardée sous
forme parce que c'est un coup critique
comme regarder le coût de ce trouve pas
ce qu'il veut
ben a posé un problème mais comme il
n'ya pas de tournage de l'ehpad accès
facile à la tour il y anime à 15 décès
dinaqua ce bien je me suis dit que ça
tenait
mais du coup parce qu'en fait ici est-ce
qu'il faut que 3 marcherait parce que en
fait après tous les trois mois je risque
de crainte d'être juste crois bien il te
dira ok le jour où tu me lançais 4 eh
ben je mange je mange je m'en fous et
après jamais la tour 17 bien sûr il dit
ennaceur europe et bien sûr d'autant
plus que tint en plus quand tu joues
toujours achète mais j'avais pas vu tu
peux me peut-être avoir détourné sept
jeux pour venir prendre ce pion ce qui
est quand même assez intéressant dans
tout jeu aurait voulu jouer tous rêvent
6 pour calmer le jeu
de calmer le jeu blanc
non ça a l'air quand même
mais mais ok c
je pense que la partie continuez comme
ça je
sais 4 les blancs ont quand même
ça a été joué d'ailleurs jeu est d'alger
s'agit d'approchés 5 à prendre parti
vous savez quand même ouais on est
balèze on est balèze surtout quand on
bouge les pièces et oui mais ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile à gela
l'ordinateur donc oui ça c'est vraiment
mais c'est mieux parce que bon faut faut
qu'on se plante devant vous déjà ça vous
fait marrer ça c'est le premier point
nous ça nous fait rage et vous savez
comment ça se passe un stuff moins que
moi mais met en rage un peu où on rigole
voilà mais du coup c'est humain c'est
tellement
bon c'est bien beau de voir le
coordinateur
c'est facile de lire un ordinateur qui
l'a beaucoup moins d'avoir qui utilise
beaucoup d'ordinateurs qui en fait bon
voilà mais nous on n'utilise pas le coup
vraiment on essaie avec nos petits
cerveaux de de trop des coûts humains
est logique les lieux il veut jouer tout
b3 directement
c'est encore une autre version
finalement
moi j'étais à ses partis pris de jouer
f5 toi ces femmes tu prends g6 et l ue
touche à rien il faut b3 ya vrai je
crois que les trois solutions sont
intéressantes
mais non on peut penser que de toute
façon c'est quand une position celle là
de résultats 1
je pense que richard rapporte il n'a pas
trop de chance de perdre cette position
j'ai l'impression que c'est un tout
petit pressing
moi je pense que ça à faire nul aussi 1
mais le seul qui peut gagner pour moi
c'est
en fait on ne le sait pas si
l'ordinateur nous empêche de progresser
pour un amateur mais effectivement il ya
peu d'amateurs qui savent bien utiliser
l'ordinateur
pour que ça ne devienne pas contre
productif comme tu le dis je pense que
je dirais le fait de l'avoir utilisé jeu
papa en tant qu'entraîneur mais en tant
que joueur aux jeunes entre 16 et 20 ans
à titre personnel j'ai appris à
l'utiliser pas me focaliser dessus même
si encore aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu
des fois être bête quand je met
l'ordinateur c'est pour ça que bacon
était en train de commenter avec souffre
on a pris le parti pris de palme est
parce que sinon même quand il est là tu
va regarder quoi tu va regarder et ça te
fait déconnecter en donc ce qui est
intéressant pour les joueurs amateurs
c'est pour le côté ouverture et être
sûrs de notre répertoire pour le côté
tactique et les quelques grosses fautes
stratégique où il ya des variations
fortes du module normalement si on prend
du recul et que l'on comprend pourquoi
et qu'on cherche par nous mêmes là ça
devient intéressant ça nous fait même
des propres exercices sur nos partis
donc la petite bestiole ça peut être
intéressant de l'utiliser mais après je
suis d'accord avec toi michel des fois
il ya des joueurs amateurs qui abusent
et qui ne jurent plus que par l'ordi
c'est un petit peu la problématique est
là tu vois que ça s'enflamme complet des
fois dans dans lé chat en disant ouais
intel il a raté ça c'était hyper facile
et même des fois plus 10 moi je sais
quand ils perso et je suis sûr que ses
fans salut a déjà arrivé de gâcher des
plus 10 et en disant ben ouais +10 donc
c'est l'équivalent d'une dame davance
mais des fois c'est vraiment pas facile
quoi il ya plus de 10 et plus disent eh
ben c'est l'idiot qui a remporté lio tu
devrais pouvoir faire les commentaires
avec nous c'est ton cou qui a été choisi
par par mamediarov et et il y aussi si
mamediarov perd aujourd'hui bas sache
que je te raterai pas je dirais que
c'est à cause du coût lilio 25 four b3
non non ça c'est un bon coup aussi c'est
un beau coup aussi il y avait il y avait
plusieurs plusieurs choix et est du coup
bah c'est vrai que toute façon si j'ai
premier set elle jouait dans la tour
s'active comme le voulait stouff et
finalement effrangé quand il avait une
structure un peu bizarre masse et
c'était un peu la même chose et tu es
mon rêve samba il y avait tout rachète
qui était quand même assez pénible donc
voilà je pense que m'hamed ici
il va simplement égaliser on est parti
pour une liquidation général
et on annonce une nulle dans la
demi-heure souffle normalement
tranquille
tranquille donc ils se sont faits
soient ces nouvelles parties quand même
un franchement ça fait plaisir de voir
des gens d échec de cette nature là à
haut niveau
rapide de combat donc c'est toujours
plaisant mais les deux joueurs soient un
peu comme ça quand même
ils s'envoient
il envoie du bois a quoi comme on dit un
est-ce qu'on irait voir ton petit
manuel top-team avenue st anton petit
prague ton petit prague allez c'est
parti
il a donné un pion alors sac en train de
nous dire nous crois moi
et j'ai repéré l'échiquier alors est ce
que c'est la transmission
ouais je suis en train de chercher je me
suis peut-être un bug chasse comme parce
que je vois pas le pion de moins mais
c'était la fausse annonce de stouff la
petite régalade et on va vous mettre la
cam
la cam qui nous intéresse
hop
avec magnus en pleine réflexion vous le
voyez à l'image
et du coup dam des deux venait de jouer
alors dam des deux on va aller à dame
ces deux on était là on est dans un
grand vide à m'accepter avec en ordre de
coups un tout petit peu particulier 1
alors que s'est-il passé pour arriver
dans cette position dams et de baies 5 a
été joué si tout à l'heure je parlais du
coup de la rupture clés à 4 qui va avoir
lieu dans un coup pas à ce coup ci mais
le coup d'après c'est très différent
puisque quand un cavalier en bien et que
je fais à 4 dans cette structure là
après beckham je mets mon cahier en d2
ces quatre là maintenu ce qu'on fait
mais 56.4 il gagne un tempo sur le
cavalier c3 qui met beaucoup plus de
temps à atteindre la cadence et 4 qui
est la case clé alors tour d un
évidement protège le fou
parce que sinon et des risques de b4
vous l'avez bien compris et maintenant
je fais à 4
et là je m'attendais à b4 et eu à chis
rachid
ben alors à 15 h is back m lacaze ces
cas toujours
mais en fait
c'est marrant quand même comme coup à
chis bon ça évite tous les cavaliers g5
mais bon ok c'était même pas une menace
et cavalier s'en va donc ok à bab
et stouff
break à quoi servent iasi sont en fait
c'est ça ma question
on comprend qu'il ya un pot de
prophylaxie voir beaucoup derrière
mais moi qui dis toujours tout fou on a
besoin de trouver quelle est la priorité
l'urgence de la position dans cette
position qui est un peu tendue dans un
certain sens même s'il n'y a pas de
menace apparente elle est quand même
plus ouverte avec des structures mobiles
puisque on voit que surtout après
apprendre et apprendre et à quoi me sert
à chis
est-ce que s'il y avait vraiment une
menace de carrier g5
ce qu'il craignait sans magnus tête
jusqu'à valegeas fin de cavale de quatre
oui j'entends bien
et je regardais si tu veux cavaliers g5
une fois qu'il va les jouer qui va être
joué est-ce que je peux pas jouer à chis
c'est peut-être pas clair en fait c'est
de la folie peut-être la position
ouais en fait oui donc à quatre on
revient sur ce hachis ce qu'est ce que
je pouvais jouer comme autre coup vous
voyez il ya des schémas pâques les incas
et g5 ashes d'alger 6 par exemple
mais j'ai l'impression qu'avec cavalier
e 5
après des fois dans ce genre de de pause
c'est pénible
on peut aussi voir
l'intérêt sans sacrifice de deux pièces
cavale et 5 h is des fois y'a des
cavaliers pro f 7
tours prend ou l' inverse un fou prend
d'abord droit prend et le roi peut être
un peu faible mais là je vois pas trop
donc j'avoue je suis un peu interloqués
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup de
coups utile mais dans ce cas là il
aurait vraiment une position difficile
magnus et je crois pas
en quoi ce hachis c'était vital stouff
je repose la question parce que sam ça
me choque légèrement si vous voulez voit
pas trop trop d'idées de vraiment manger
ouais ouais non j'essaie de justifier
c'est la prophylaxie purquoi
mai mais
[Musique]
bon j'ai pas trouvé ainsi je pose la
question souffre c'est honnête je suis
comme toi je suis coincé mais je vois
pas en quoi achi c'est ce qu'on aime
c'est quand même vulgariser les coûts de
ces de ses top players
et à chis ouais c'est assez étonnant
et du coup après apprend bea pro b dames
2 d'un b6 qu'il aurait pu jouer
peut-être avant eux quatre
tours 8 ça c'est normal
pour activer la tour face à la dame et
d'amd deux maintenant fouet fuite
et c'est vrai que
par rapport au fait de mettre le foin f8
si vous voulez le fait de contrôler à kg
5 c'est quand même une bonne chose
maintenant parce que typiquement va les
cavaliers g5 aurait été était très
gênant donc je pense que la tour
magne aussi la tête anticipé le fait de
trouver la bonne architecture de pièces
le bon schéma de pièces et par rapport à
ce bon schéma de pièces tour huit fois
f8 il a considéré que cavaler g5 avec
pénible dans cette situation
particulièrement parce que ce n'était
pas le cas précédemment et du coup il a
anticipé avec un petit h is en disant
j'ai le temps de le faire
tandis que prague il essaie de mettre
les pièces
sur magnus
ce qui est un petit peu pénible dans la
position de prague c'est qu'ils
veuillent il va y être pour sa paire de
fous j'ai l'impression
donc je pense
malheureusement
or moi je suis carrément pour mon petit
poulain vous savez moi je rien d'assez
bon fan number one mais
[Musique]
de possibilités
sa majorité
oui alors il faut savoir comment jouer
ici quand même avec les noirs c'est
peut-être pas si évident puisque
cavaliers prendrait 5 laisser le
cavalier blanc arrivé en dessin que
c'est quand même peut-être légèrement
désagréable encore ou pas c'est
compliqué j'ai aussi plus on prend qui
est aussi une qui peut être ses défauts
et de menaces avoir fait passer mais je
pense que cavale en dessin grave
on a besoin c réactive toutes les pièces
blanches
ok on voit fois la jauge qui indique le
bel avantage les noirs
mais je suis toujours un petit peu
ouais je cherche sur long terme hockey
j'aime bien mais les noirs mais comment
je fais maintenant parce que vous voyez
mon fou c'est 8 j'ai besoin d'activer un
moment
comment je mets en place mon schéma pour
que ça soit tranquille
est ce que j'ai le droit
je regardais b4 comme coup mais j'ai
ensuite cavalier à 4 et quand même payer
parce que je donne la case c4 au fou
puisque globalement j'aimerais bien me
séparer du food et 5,1
en le prenant et après réussira activé
mon fou c'est 8
mais j'arrive pas à faire ça si
facilement que cela est
ce que dans une position comme ça
souffle j'ai le droit de jouer un coup
comme
c4
c4 prise est prise je trouve ça bizarre
intuitivement alors qu'on contrôle tous
deux les cases avec nos pions voilà je
regarde ces 4 c'est simplement que fin
ouais j'aimerais bien
trouver une architecture harmonieuse
avec mes pièces paris la gb 4 janvier
lors des quatre cavaliers qu'elle
prendrait 5 c'est ça à l'astuce et voilà
c'est ça qui va tout de suite prendre
l'aventage c'est pour ça qu'il ya
avantage on arrive comme on voulait
appliquer le foot cases blanches sans
mettre le cavalier en plein centre là on
comprend touche je pense ça à permettre
au foot cases blanches des noirs de
rayonner dans la position aïe aïe aïe là
c'est le coup dur en fait c'est le petit
truc qui nous manquait c'est tout
simplement sur cavale erakat là on a un
cavalier prendrait 5 intermédiaires qui
attaquent la dame aux poèmes après
savoir parce que j'ai encore passé
aura la part de fou et donc fait avoir
cette position apparaît comme très très
difficile peut-être soit frais c'est le
ça dépend des fois
alors fou des 6 ou d'amd six
jeunes dames 1 je peux même aller rester
sur quasiment aucun gagnant 1,4 respire
pas
la joie de vivre ouais ouais mais après
peut-être j'aurai je pourrais mettre en
b2c 4
ouais mon faux vient très rapidement à 6
mais bon en tout cas c'est clair c'est
la manière de 40 adhérents que la
position
maintenant on va préparer et blanc mais
iliad perd de foot chez noir est casse
blanche et
sa
paire de faux en plus ce match ol dames
le fou de cases blanches qui va rayonner
dans la position en passant par à 6 il
arrivera à trouver on le voit tous des
cases forte et a pesé sur la position
pourrait aussi sortir par là à terme
aucun échange de dames
du coup ça va être très dur
on a quand même des pions isolé même si
je suis allé passer sur blanc donc ça va
pas être facile le cavalier à 4 les
pièces vous commencent à manquer de
coordination
c'est pas mal la séquence quand même ce
qu'est ce que ces classes ce qui fait qu
en scène d'anticipation tour 8 houphouet
fuite tout le jeu semble certain sens
mais quelle classe non vraiment
d'un quinzaine c'est hyper agréable à
regarder pour le côté stratégique je
trouve que c'est ouf
en fait
ce qui fait la différence est là
pour en parler avec samy en fait dans
les ouvertures c'est tellement difficile
maintenant
on va dire des
pollutions dynamique des pollutions
tourne vraiment l' avantage avec une
couleur
de notre coopération est tellement est
tellement immense c'est tellement énorme
pour chaque joueur qu'en fait travailler
la tactique
et travailler dur car c'est bien un
petit peu tu vois quand je veux dire en
fait quand vous allez là sur mon
allégeance à son niveau
stratégique c'est le seul d'ailleurs il
avait vraiment une compétence
distinctive par rapport à ça c'est pour
ça c'est un autre qui la numéro un
mondiale
par rapport aux autres il a une façon
pas différente de travailler je pense
que c'est juste qu'il a way il ya
quelque chose en plus sur ce côté là et
du coup c'est ça c'est énorme
et d'ailleurs j'ai vu je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu aussi que
ça y est on avait annoncé dans la demi
heure là nul et ben richards rapporté le
choix qui m'avait dit rov bas il ya eu
nul hein ça va pas manquer le principe
de liquidation qui a été entamée
alors il ya les lieux qui a posé une
petite question sur foot pro f7 la place
de cavaliers à 4 qu'on n'a pas qu'on n'a
pas vraiment analyser donc sur b4 tu
voulais faire [ __ ] première cette
folle jeunesse trois premiers sets et
cavaliers des 5 bon tu affaiblis le roi
sur case blanche mehta plus de foot
recasement jeu du coup
alors fois de com précise ce qui a un
coût important dans cette position c'est
le coup avec avec les noirs ici
dams issiaka ssl mais ce qu'il ya
vraiment cas et c'est cet emprunt cattin
mois lélio peut-être quand tu menaces e5
peut-être c'est ça
vraiment ou pas
moi c'était rigolo
restez supra chaussettes position
avec l'idée de 5
[Applaudissements]
ben c'est mignon tout cas alors
non ok peut-être ont fait d'un me 6 cas
et c'est cette ça marche pas iliad à me
casse je crois et sur 1,5 g 5 c'est ça
que je voulais jouer souffle
un g5 direct traiter comme ça
même idée mais c'est vraiment
parce que
5 non mesdames f5 tu peux peut-être
jouer aux dames aussi juste dans le sens
inverse
est en fait là tu te renvoie
la bonne idée c'est g5 pour enlever la
dame de f4 mais c'était une belle idée
lélio à nouveau un très très bien
ça fait plaisir ce genre d'idée
on va juste voir vite fait comment ils
sont accordés sur le principe de
liquidation regarder à la faim
auxquelles nul tour trois tours 3 ils
sont d'accord il y avait eu four b3
voilà sa santé un la liquidation tour à
chaque poussée 4 on mange je te mange
mange allez hop go nul qu'elle pourrait
y avoir un peu de travail mais à leur
niveau tour 3 contour trois ils savent
que ça va s'équilibrer ya pas de
problème particulier dans les deux camps
voilà et du coup ça va ça va vite faire
mieux de cette position donc ils n'ont
pas attendu mais c'est une vraie nul de
combat même si nuls en 29 coups assez
rapide en termes de temps passé devant
l'échiquier la partie était super
intéressante
et d'ailleurs
oui c'est ça et quand on parle de partie
intéressante je pense aussi à la purge
qu'on avait vu entre grands delius écart
yakine est-ce que ça c'est
ce que ça s'est amélioré cette partie ou
pas parce que je trouvais ça c'était
lens est parti on s'endormait un petit
peu
ah bah là ça a vraiment avancer
et on a une position archi bizarre comme
stouff par rapport à tout à l'heure elle
est beaucoup plus créa visuellement
parlant donc à part de flou pour les
noirs mais des plantes replay donc ayant
triplé ça peut être une faiblesse et ça
peut aussi être pas mal parce qu'elle
est un triplé sa contrôle quand même pas
mal de cases avec le roi blanc ne pas
participer à
nous c'est la can que je mange le droit
noir non plus
à 50/50 partie
mais bouge on regarde juste vite fait
comme on est arrivé là puisque nous
serons s'ennuyer tout à l'heure et on
s'était arrêté à h4 donc hk tout
grand des lieux sont disait qu'il avait
peut-être
enfin il avait joué safe avait tenté un
petit truc à hk h4 on n'était pas
inquiet regard des cavaliers g5 pour
essayer de d'être entreprenant
vous prend g5 bien sûr h projet 5 l on a
créé un petit truc en achète donc b5
cavani prend un chef roy g8 fou détroit
et l'idée c'était fou prend h4 est jeté
en fermant le cavalier sauf qu'on ait
lieu s'il avait calculé plus loin j'ai
trois pas de case pour le fou à part des
huit f4 je veux faire une mission
sauvetage comme un cavalier
f6 pas de mission sauvetage ou g6 même
si je fais pas de mission sauvetage te
bloque
c'est complètement parti en live cette
position c'est si simple commise la
brigade et il ya des gars des menaces de
matsilo fauves n'a pas quoi mais vous
voyez un si le fouet des huit partis
partei avec tours 7 et s'il vous et 8 17
pendant que par terre il y avait tous
envie que ma tempête les pièces ont du
mal à bouger donc ces quatre états ont
dépensé 4 avec l'idée de vraiment s'est
débloquée la position
c'est marrant parce que la partie est
dédiée pas génial au début un prométhée
pas être très excitante et en fait
elle est devenue hyper sympa a contrario
de la partie entre rapporté mamediarov
au final il ya nulle relativement rapide
en moins de trente coups alors que la
partie et des folles dès le début et là
on voit la jauge qui s'excitent en plus
que les la position tellement atypique
que c'est dur aussi pour les deux
joueurs c'est marrant il n'est pas venu
en hausse est là haut
c'est rigolo je pense qu'il vient pas eu
cette si vous voulez alors que ça paraît
être un peu facile il ya peut-être tout
simplement tour des huit suites food et
6 et je vais devoir me barrer
parce que
on est tous rêvent satura faut 8
on se fera banane
donc attention à l'aspect visuel mais
les joueurs connaissent bien cela
donc
non elle fout des six
chez welch et
je fais attention parce que là ça sent
qu'on peut se faire mater dont il faut
vraiment être très vigilant
très très chaude
et ça c'est bizarre parce que l'option
qui travaille avant tout aux 5 pouces et
[Musique]
peut-être que les joueurs sont
oui ce que kaya qui ne voudraient c'est
rentrer dans une finale
où le cavalier achète et le foot j'ai
six sont coincés
c'est le cinquième proposer les changes
de tours parlons tous mes excuses moi je
refais mon roi très coincé
plus
oui je pensais à fois ci sous b 5 x 4
mais déjà évolué wafa qui a x 6 à 4 ans
à 4 et vous il a réglé matelas s'en est
allé chercher vous faut la donner aux
enfers
mais c'est tout l'enjeu pour ces 4 je
dois pouvoir une fois à 6 etf ou deux et
à voir contre je
alors stop j'ai une question
donc x 6 ok ça marche pas mais je viens
de voir j'avais pas forcément vu au
départ ah oui non je voulais jouer
tourage crois tu reprends achète
mais qui a cavalé g5 peut-être non
faut 5
il ya le feu aux cinq souffre du coup
je m'en sers pour ressortir mon cavale
du coup c'est pour ça que dans cette
position sur tours 4 on comprend mieux
le coup de karuïa keane tour des 5 pour
éviter
tout le monde comprend maintenant il n'y
a plus qu'à voir les g5 mon cavalier
bien dans une prison un cat on pouvait
le comprendre comme ça il y aura jamais
fumé cinq
tours eux deux en garde la tête sur le
fou donc il a enlevé son fou on peut
imaginer à kariat keynes qui l'a vu tout
ça
je visualise la fouille
8e fois en 8 simplement fou première
voie pour un chef donc n'importe quoi
tour 3 tours 5
pour comprendre
et roye b 1 et on attend alors
voilà en fait on voit que le fou le x
1,6 malheureusement il est enfermé il a
pris la peine à faire
et les pieds soeurs blanches peuvent
rien faire un don peuvent essayer de
jouer avec b 4 mais n'en manque pas pour
manger en passant
est ce que va pas y avoir nulle tout de
suite
les deux amis sont en france et non
avant bras bien
est ce que c'est une question qui peut
un petit peu au premier fond raciste les
gens jetaient aura bien on aura bien
droit de soutenir avant droit à deux
aces que alors c'est une question bête
hein mais est ce que les noirs
menacerait pas qu'on me fouquet ça je
regarderai mais en fait après imaginons
donc je prends
puis on prend
et je fais quoi
ok mais même même x 8 c'est nul en un
coup
voilà des fondateurs
ward en ligne en fait juste l'idée c'est
que je sacrifie mon fou qui sachant que
tu étais en cavale et on fout ne
joueront pas de toute façon mais après
ce qu'on n'ait pas gagné qu'un seul four
vraiment quelque chose
et même peut-être que roy à 2 eh ben ça
empêche complètement fou b5 et qui se
dit au moins y'a pas contre jouer puis
on répète comme ça
je pense qu'ils vont faire nul bientôt
en fait il veut attendre 40e mais ya pas
de ya pas de coups
pas de coup c'est une position de de
quasi forteresse commune en fait parce
qu'il n'a pas assez d'endroits de
passage si vous voulez
mais en tout cas la position elle est
assez sympa ils ont dû être méfiant tous
les deux
de la pause la petite pause que vous
attendez tous avec impatience
donc
juste avant avant la pause je remarque
une petite remarque de ares galina qui
ne lit j'ai l'impression que magnus a
touché et remis en place la pièce que
venait de jouer son adversaire or il ya
le droit
1res de toucher une pièce si tu dit jah
double pour la replacer sur sa case donc
sinon il ya la règle qui est touchée
pièce à jouer évidemment dans bateaux
tous les matches officiels mais là dans
son cas ils sont surveillés ya les
caméras de partout donc s'il a touché il
jouera et s'il ne joue pas cette équipe
qui l'avait comment dirais-je pas fait
pièce où ces pièces à jouer mais bien
dit jah double voilà
donc c'est juste pour d'autres all way
à temps ah si si si je sais je sais je
sais alors l'accent va être moyen mais
pour moi c'est ayad geste
et très franchement franchement fille
hyper content parce que je n'étais pas
du tout sûrs d'en sortir avec avec ça
en fait au début je me suis dit sans
doute faut dire jadot bon français tu
peux pas
laisser ça
à néandertal qui me dit appelle maman
parce que c'est ça normalement que je
fais dans ces cas là il a bien compris
comment ça marchait et en espagnol je
suis peut pas dire parce que j'ai fait
allemand première langue mais je sais
pas le dire en allemand
je vais faire un hedge fund igm je crois
que ces excuses moi
voilà ce que je te propose toof
c'est tout ce que je peux faire mais non
je peux pas j'ai pas faire mieux je suis
content et via bien une nulle entre car
jaeckin et ni le grand des lieux ça va
être super pour partir en pause et tu
voulais le dire en espagnol avant tout
bon
copain go
[Musique]
away we go d'accord ok et du coup je
vous ai mis pour l'instant le petit
échiquier entre
entre
magnus et
prague honda
chien tout petit peu étonné que c'est
pas encore jouer à wii voilà c'était
juste le temps de la mise à jour arrive
il ya bien eu les changes du fou des
cinq des blancs qui a attendu pendant
très longtemps il a gardé cette tension
pendant très longtemps et maintenant
magnus va taper les cases blanches avec
avec son faux et prague n'a pas voulu
avoir l'option basse et de stouff il a
fait une petite infidélité pour une fois
stouff on va bien voir quoi bien voir ce
que ça va donner
ça promet va y avoir une analyse
mouvementée entre prague et s'ouvre ce
soir le débrief et goûté on vous laisse
un instant on va lancer la petite page
de pub comme d'hab et on vous dit a tout
de suite pour la suite du tata steel
allez à bientôt les gens
[Musique]
à
nous
et
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
allez on est reparti les amis et ça
faisait un petit moment qu'on n'avait
pas été voir notre pépite française qui
est en difficulté dans le tata steel des
challengers le grand maître marc andré
maury dit
alors sabots elle dure il va se battre
jusqu'au bout et aujourd'hui encore
opposé un grand maître à plus de 10 me
scie 2600 c'est aussi pour ça qu'il est
en difficulté effectivement il est
peut-être pas dans la forme de sa vie
mais au-delà de ça on avait dit que le
plateau enfin c'était très relevé et
si souffle le début de partie avait été
très difficile est ce que ma connerie
n'est pas en train de pouvoir revenir et
d'accrocher le demi point dans cette
position il vient de jouer un e 5
1 c'est ambitieux
puisque bien que vous allez peut être
doit créer des choses parce que dans mon
espace que nous avons bien avancé mais
là il était une façon dans une pollution
aura juste si l'un
vous pouvez il a vu le plan comme
peut-être organiser avec doublage détour
sur la colonne ah ouais il avait fait
quelque chose de bizarre au début on
s'en rappelle actour c'est un four ashes
tour
c-26 d'accord fou c'est un pour proposer
les changes fous ces quatre comme tu
l'avais dit aussi pour ses huit fois aux
trois cas il décide donc voilà t'y plus
blanc a
travaillé tour c'est un franchement il
avait des choses assez bizarres avec les
bleus un
cahier français 4 kim une décision un
petit peu étonnant parce que ça rétabli
la structure de pions mais il avait
trouvé une idée car les v6
pour forcer ces cinq cas et d5 faut être
bien sûr de soi parce que les pions
blancs il avance vraiment facilement g3
pour empêcher les f4 sans doute à chis
h4 pour fixer l aile roi et vii et la
torah trois étés jeu par le joueur blanc
est sûre à 6 tours 1
et la marque andré baril à trouver quand
même le saint qui s'emmène le bon coup
là pour pour compliquer la position
alors si jamais je mange le 5 avec le
pion
probablement tu as le cac va les prendre
3 et principes de liquidation cavaliers
près trois là on serait proche d'une
égalité tour 33 et tout reprend ces cinq
là je mangerai assises manger assis jeu
quand même prendre de la tour je pense
au
jeu peut même penser à commencer à
respirer jouer pour gagner cette
position bon j'en suis loin depuis le
départ mais et mon nom mais à un moment
donné tu vas réussir à manger le pion
eux moi j'aurais pu tomber ce sera
symétrique nouveau des pions ça ça va ça
nul et donc on voit bien que déjà qu'on
ne peut pas manger le pire le sens
qu'avec le pion
si on mange avec le cas d'ali en ce sens
qui sera la même chose il ya on va juste
inclure fou prend 25
dans la variante exactement et donc du
coup sur cinq qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer
c'est sain c'est vraiment un coup
intéressant
non plus ça arrive au bon moment parce
qu'il restait que 6 minutes un marc
landry 15 minutes pour son adversaire et
du coup ben ça peut permettre comment
dirais-je
de complètement revenir dans la partie
il a de bonnes chances là
et
donc est ce que pour réveiller s'ils
sont mangés assiste maintenant
si je m'en lasse maintenant tu as mangé
en d4 on rit quand tu vas manger que le
flou et 3 et 5
non j'ai du mal à trouver davantage
une idée qui me vient
est ce que je peux jouer ces six
il faire des progrès huawei ou tout
reprend ainsi ses baies prend 1,6
nous avions passé on est un pion passé
avancé alors je commençais six souffre
donc pions prend
tout reprend
tout reprend epyon prend
donc on aurait un plan passer à 2 càs de
la dame c'est un toujours un petit plus
ça c'est certain mais
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour gagner
pas sûr
et sur ces six sinon des français 6
cette position jugé que c'était moi mais
peut-être pas parce que j'ai peut-être
des idées de tourbe et un tour bessette
c'est pas mal aussi un
way puis à ça aussi bon
ouais tour ses sets ça irait peut-être
avec tours b 1
bon faut voir un pascal 5 faut voir
qu'il ya eu cinq en l'air aussi un
toujours dans les variantes
ce que précédemment vous rappelle au
début au début de la variante quant à
eux cinquièmes jouer
évidemment si je prends un cinquième
pioncer 5 qui peut être perdu à
cavaliers 1er 3 donc dès que je joue
c'est si on prend et par exemple si on
prend 1,6 c'est intéressant il ya eu 5
éventuellement l'air
oui vraiment géant des cartes
et je mange du fou j'imagine bien ici
logique ne pas donner
et si manger cavaliers prend il ya une
petite pression comme ceci quand celle
ci s'est paré dit que le projet pour le
gain
donc là n'ont pas non mais c'est ça la
nôtre d'être une bonne option pour jouer
alors il a beaucoup de choses à regarder
parce que le croyais il a quand même
hein c'est quand même une belle force et
blanc bonnet maire d'avoir un peu craqué
avec les blancs parce qu'il avait
vraiment ouais je suis pas seul à
souffrir de
gagner
mais je le vois bien joué ces six cas un
maghreb lente parce que pour l'instant
stouff j'ai pas vu d'autre option pour
conserver le pressing
ça me paraît une petite clé pour pour
continuer à essayer de faire mal
aux gens ici savent rien faire manger
ainsi ce qu'ils veulent justement j'ai
une foi
vois tu peux tout le mangeant à 6 mais à
la fin il va manger en d4
et il va manger aux séances à 100 et
voici la cavale et prendre 3 un jour
peut-être aussi et tu vas finir par
perdre en fait
le pion c5 d'accord là ce qui est de
nouveau
avec ans tous deux n'ont pas on n'a pas
la caméra de morandini de renom seydoux
dans toi bien connu
dans l'échangeur on n'a pas les calmes
ok bon on a peut-être fait suffisamment
parce que ça n'a pas joué un du côté du
joueur tchèque
on peut retourner maintenant sur les
parties du à et on viendra voir marc
andry puisque c'est le line up qui
commence
donc magnus magnus qu'est ce qui nous
fait ils travaillent les cases blanches
et ça
on s'est arrêté après tour prenez cinq
dames 6
tours d un été jouée avec une pression
sur le cavaly 17 d'accord
tour à 8 et sur dame c1
il a appris en 1 4
ok qu'est ce qu'il a vu se trouvent
surtout reprend 17
je me le demande
dans toutes les pièces sont bien placés
mais
a oui c'est tout bête en fait c'est fou
prend tout reprend et ses 400 en août
oui
donc on peut se demander puisque on dit
souvent que deux pièces au plus qu'une
tour
et là il ya sans doute un problème ce
que c'est qu'à tirer encore tour
descartes
et se trouve nous a trouvés d'un me
6,2 6,6 encore tour des 3 et maintenant
c'est cap peut-être
voyez un l'idée c'est de taper pions b3
alors
on voit quelques cavaliers à 4 en l'air
dont il ya quelque chose forcément
non mesdames si c'était pas mal
il ya du jeu en tout cas
bon et c'est sûr qu'ils aient qui l'a vu
tout cas grosse pression à
sur les deux joueurs
est-ce qu'il a joué à prague
sinon c'est le pion de moins donc est-ce
que ce que tu as un autre choix que tout
reprend 17
pts est de mettre la petite gamme de
demain cnuced prague d'ailleurs pour
fêter ça
toujours pas la cam un tac ce risque pas
d'arriver j'espère encore peut-être
alors voilà
c'est drôle sans calmes pour apparaître
peut-être hockey ici
ouais c'était pas mal de pub sur le
maillot de duda effectivement
j'ai pas vu son short cycliste par
contre
même
c'est pas le dress code
h
3à jeu trois petits coups de prenda qui
dit aller à toi magnus tue mais pas tant
que ça à améliorer h3 il ya plus de
menace demain du couloir
sont forts quand même les mecs arrivent
à jouer leur âge 3h hisse au bon moment
alors qu'on dit pas trop le faire
normalement
à manger un pion clé en main maintenance
du
oui en fait mais blanc contrôle bien et
noir
ce qu'il faudrait faire soulever sainte
et je suis fait un coup j'en vois
donc du coup il faut que je trouve un
coup et cavaliers b8 s'il priait le pion
ses 5 sur chaque coup je vois quelque
chose du genre c'est tout dépend des 7
je prépare cavaliers à 6
il suffit d'un
alors tu pourrais cavaliers futur
qu'est-ce que du beau souffle pardon je
sais pas là puisque je joue pourtant
dans le coup cavada réussis sur 27 pour
pour défendre le cavaly 17 est menacée
cavaliers ces fameux 6
pour aussi camélidés 6 dans l'air
avec
elle se trouve ça risque d'atteindre 11
i'm not aussi puisque regarde quatre
minutes pour prague lambda
si
c'est hyper cher au vu de londres où
qu'ils ont joué donc je vous rappelle la
cadence 1h40 pour 40 coups avec 50
minutes au rajout de temps pour 20 coups
et encore 15 minutes
pour finir la partie avec trente
secondes parcours depuis le début de
partie est du coup là on est au 25e coup
et il le reste si lucas 45 contre quatre
pour jeu 15 coups donc c'est la
pollution n'est pas évidente donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment en position
compliquée
chaque fois que tu me dises âge je jette
un oeil
avant de forest ce que c'est souvent que
tu me cache quand tu m'incite à regarder
car la scène tu me cache que vonn forest
est sans doute en train de prendre un
avantage assez nets contre visite voir
qui va gagner là non est-ce que c'est
pas le gain direct devant de forrest
alors je ne sais pas on peut aller voir
ce que tu veux rapido un petit un petit
rôle c'est vrai qu'on voit là on voit la
cour qui est monté alors attends
moi juste regarder la position je me
suis les foutus et oui et ça sent
presque le seul bon direct
ça fait plaisir
et oui arrive on aurait
promis je crois pas trop on lui dit va
sauver celle là parce que là il ya des
dessous des 5
max affirme alain food et 5 da me sens
pas tout regardé mais bon sang que c'est
le bord du gouffre pour pour visite qui
pourtant que c'est un tournoi
exceptionnel mais vont de forêt s'il est
capable ah oui ça gagne tout de suite
regarde toof d'aveux 5e' adam prend pour
fc tourcoing et sète
et oui vous avez volé parce que voilà
donc la lasser il va tous se reprendre
et on peut on peut mettre la cam un
instant quand même pour voir voilà je
vis dit au plus mal
il sait qu'il est foutu c'est toujours
dur pour ces joueurs là tellement fort
mais il est coincé de chez coincé de
bien sûr
il va simplifier je comprends et ça
d'ailleurs été joués
ah non j'étais un petit peu plus
20 prend
le verrai si ça a été joué
voyez là il ya plein de gars maintenant
tout reprendre et 7 on peut se faire
plaisir
et le principal plaisir c'est fou aux
six derrière
à faux si ce
voyage était entendue avec ton fou
bessette fous ces sites ont gagné aussi
enfin bon c'est la totale
vous avez jusqu'à l'excès sentiment
clair quand même ouais
non mais je rejoue faut aussi s'en fout
aussi c'est vraiment
d'ailleurs c'est par accident
eh ben le pauvre vie dit vous allez
regarder la caméra on va le voir la edad
et
il est pas content du tout
il sait qu'à 0 espoir mais bon il espère
quand même un petit et quelque chose
il est en train de regarder stouff là
il ajoute un regard noir il a entendu
stouff
l is too far est l'art est de me parler
neuf cases blanches comme ça
il regarde
là je sais pas trop ce qu'ils espèrent
un sou dans cette position c'est
étonnant qu'ils n'abandonnent pas
jusque là il ya vraiment zéro espoir je
crois
qu'il va laisser son cavalier et sa tour
donc bon
balaci l'abandon de pâma parce que c'est
un super joueur d'échecs vie dit il est
jugé peut-être qu'ils râlent parce qu'il
se dit bon
j'étais super bien dans le tournoi
là ils regardent ils gardent en corse
tout froid
elle dit mais c'est pas possible
passé à côté de sa partie
bon voilà je l'attendais l'abandon là
c'était juste histoire de ne pas quitter
le l'échiquier avant l'abandon de vie
dit moi je station il peut pas jouer le
coup la vie peut rien jouer
donc
je pense qu'il va qui va arrêter là
et voilà ça y est
c'est fait je pense que van de forest
baidu est et doit être assez assez
satisfait un parti du jour
ok
tout le monde est content du coup on est
content finale voilà
ça fait bien plaisir
on a eu raison d'aller faire une petite
infidélité à un magnus tout juste avant
de retourner chez manu j'avais juste
envie de voir stouff on a regardé cette
partie contre chant clandestine qu
est juste avant d'aller voir magnuson
risque après de ne plus avoir le temps
il ya toujours un petit pressing des six
penco comme l'annoncé l'ouverture 1 mais
bon deux minutes contre 15 on va pas
rester là trop longtemps
ouais mais les deux pions peut-être
davantage et doudin caruana ça donne
quoi c'est égal elsa et note un peu
moins prononcée annoncé pas égales du
tout le
la cabane de
la cabane de duda est en train de se
faire détruire par par le trail de
fabiano on ira voir ça tout à l'heure
après le zaï note de prague d'ananda
contre oui à la tension la up
de jouer ouais mais il ne le met pas
encore à ça y est je vais t'en
réactualisé 3,22 pour prague nanda une
40 pour magnus donc c'est hyper chaud
derniers coups joués dam des deux par
prague d'ananda est avant tout racette
c'est pas mal tour à 7 quand même ils
avaient bien défendu peut-être avec une
moins bonne pièce que la dame ce que
souffre tous parlé d'un mot sida mais
c'est vrai que touré à s'être finalement
il utilise une pièce moins importante
pour bétonner la position est sûre d'amd
de il a choisi dame g6 pour laisser
respirer un peu ça tours 8 donc il en
train de réorganiser ses pièces
ouais
ouais ouais toujours et je vous remets
de la cam de magnus
voilà ça va être un zélote haletant
entre les le numéro un mondial
et le jeune indien prague nalanda le
poulain deux touffes
et si tu veux voir du sahb arrivée bas
faire forcément un gros gros exploit de
pride and honda aujourd'hui
à ce serait un juste retour des choses
après la très très jolie partie
devant de forest
au classement donc vous appelez un
mamediarov il a déjà fait nul contre
richard rapporte sont quatre et demi et
4 et il ya eu
la défaite surprise 2 du beauf contre
anish giri qui a se retrouve du coup à
quatre points il enchaîne du coup il bat
caruana son adversaire vient pas il se
retrouve à quatre points complètement en
course je trouve ça incroyable alors
qu'il était mal dans le tournoi
et là attention les yeux parce qu'on a
un gros oeil note devant nous
et
une
magnus deux minutes 14 coup à jouer on
va franchement c'est un peu comme si on
commenté une sorte de speech est ce là
je trouve c'est ça va être autre chose
sauf que bale y aura pas de match donc
faut pas craquer
rien à voir cavaliers h4 que jouer
mais ça c'est déjà un petit peu gâté
l'histoire on voit on voit notre evans
croître et il ya plutôt de raison il a
été peut-être un petit peu long et
maintenant
magnus doit se dire qu'il est mal autant
mais il va essayer de jouer simple
bof
en fait les
points des raisons
personnelles et jolie les contacts n'ont
rien c'est exactement ça
illégal montage en fait il y avait
espéré beaucoup matin il a fait le test
du génie qu'était négative et
l'intéressé a été fait qu'il ne prend
pas la réponse pour l'instant et du coup
ils ont envie de jouer un romantique
contre viry avec un masque est en fait
un
sentiment de me refuser par principe de
jouer demain sinon
il est normalement ce n'est pas bien de
ne pas la peine y en a beaucoup moins de
trois
forfaits demeure c'est un peu dommage
parce que voilà mais
c'est un peu normal
chaque soir à celles vivant dans ses
tripes dans le tournoi ait eu mais je
trouve qu'un de ses travaux demain
[Musique]
les cours je vais par magnus dames 6
il est maintenant
beaucoup mieux il faut juste qu'ils
arrivent à sortir de la pression mais ce
qui menace pas
des choses comme dame de à terme
c'est bien dans un note de jouer
cavalier f5 ça met une petite pression
ça c'est un coup à la stouff cavaliers
f5 regarder ouais ouais il est
opportuniste dans le zag note qu'on met
les oreilles pointues près du roi
voilà
et attention prague
[Musique]
jiri un pompier
c'est moche pour le tournoi aussi dans
un tournoi fermé carmack fasse force est
forfait pardon à le petit sekkat de
magnus
un c4 est ce que c'était prévu
c'est hyper chaud là le destin
comment gérer cette pression parce que
tu sais stouff il ya des dames des
cadres de folie d'un
g7 en l'air et tout ça
il ya toulouse g7 genre fou g7 la foux
g7 on n'y comprend plus rien
dire qu'est ce qu'on fait sur fou j'ai
sept souffre
c'est chaud non
non un cavalier prendre ou à prendre dam
des cats échec je ramasse la torah
7d buffon saddam des quatre mais là
ces dames des cats il a préféré des
quatre direct
c'était l'idée mais j'avais pas dans
quel sens le jouer si tu veux
en fait dans des caves direct je me suis
dit
je me suis dit qu'il ya des risques par
exemple de ces 3 ou des choses comme ça
c'est pour ça que j'ai claqué angers7
d'abord mais bon on attend je me suis
dit oui tour à quatre essais 3 peut-être
un moment
il a joué simplement cavaliers f6 magnus
mais sans nous de la boulette 1 2 on
verra un souffle mais il a peut-être
raté le coche avec bam des cartes il
avait peut-être justement moyen de ce
que c'était pas un hasard si je faisais
tout projet 7 on n'a toujours pas trouvé
je remonte pas le moment pour vous
laisser les notes mais
c'était un peu plus excitant fou g7
parce que maintenant
n'a pas moi donc je suis sans fil et
stouff
et jouets je vous fais un set c'était
pas bien quoi ouais parce que j'avais
tout autour des 5 ok
donc ça y est c'est en train de
se déliter un petit peu
c'est ça le problème je suis d'accord
avec toi jadis
c'est celle annulée parce
que
alors là il est lui aussi il est
hélas ces ballons c'est ballot et prague
prague en difficulté
il a mangé ses huit peut-être le dernier
coup possible
par défaut je vous sais quoi deux
secondes près canada
et du coup et là comme
il a comme tout en l'air
d'en prendre cinq cavaliers prenait 5 je
pense à perd tout de suite moi
puisqu'on va arriver à égalité
matérielle avec un pion b2 et ça va être
la bande ont quasiment bientôt
et on peut vous dire un des
cinq a eu lieu
simplement cavalli grand
voile à l as éperon b2 va régler le cas
de premier mandat avec cavaliers ces
trois dernières
semaines en tout cas cette fois et il ya
tour qui protège
tour à 8 aussi
c'est bien en magnus paris l'a vu tout
re de aussi et prénom ahava bientôt
abandonner doit être dépité
mais bon
c'est fort en magnus avec baignoire et
peugeot tout ce qu'il veut mais à la fin
ils gagnent
qu'est-ce qui a été belle cette partie
stofile attention du fou dessins qu'il
n'a jamais pris ce faux bond
revoir ses parties mettaient bien
comme que rien faire
ok on va vite filé parce qu'à d'autres
partis très intéressante
on voit les sur duda caruana on est au
38e coup ses fins du zaï note et c'est
un joli bazar aussi même si on peut
quand même considérer que nous da est
mal en point dans un note puisque son
roi est beaucoup plus faible
très clairement
[Musique]
c'est quand tu quand tu m'as
way s'est attaché bravo stouff c'est
l'allemand donc je suis spécialiste ouf
voilà de
10 15 en allemand je sais plus mais
vraiment au moins bons mois un niveau
universitaire quoi tu vois
un peu comme l'anglais quoi tu as sais
c'est cadeau
[Musique]
ouais
et en petit français marquant dream
aurait dit je peux peut-être aller voir
vite fait le line up puisque là ça bouge
pas trop ça revient de bouger mais c'est
un pressing c'est la fin du zaï note
tout rêve des 8es j'ai l'impression qu'à
roanne a un petit peu raté puisque on
voit que la jauge et à monter mais on va
aller voir peut-être marque andry si ça
te va tout
olalala à bas il ya eu des choses c'est
la fin du zaï note et c'est une position
on a vu l'âge on a vu la jauge s'exciter
donc on va pas se laisser oui en tout
cas qu'on sait que maintenant marc andré
ne gagnera pas et sort le savez quand
même depuis un moment mais les pions
adversaires sont très très avancé
et risquent d'avancer encore sans
pouvoir être trop dérangé
ça risque de faire mal alors on va voir
on était tout à l'heure a eu 5 et la
main proposition ctc si c'est le joueur
a joué b prend à tout simplement
tour prend à tour prend un pion prend
est fou prend 1,6 waouh
grande classe
vous
magnifique franchement bravo à nguyen en
fait marc andré avait trouvé une belle
ressources avec 1,5 et le son adversaire
a trouvé une contrepoint tu de haute
volée qu'on n'avait pas du tout évoqué
avec stouff
et il se retrouve à quatre pions pour la
pièce
c'est joli hein et puis maintenant
c'est une vraie galère à jouer
on voit qu'elle est pire qu'avant
honnêtement
ce qui est très pénible c'est que la
position est perdante et qu'en plus elle
guyenne viendra récupérer tout son temps
tout comme marc andré marc andrieu
position très très difficile
donc on peut retourner maintenant dans
le à parce qu'on va pas regarder ça
c'est dur mais force est de constater
qu'ils jouent pas des joueurs facile
tous les jours quand on voit ce qu en
guyane et
lui a mis boigny yen il était second du
tournoi avant la partie donc en gagnant
il sera un demi point de derrida et ziki
qui est seul en tête
mais c'est l'outsider de ce tournoi là
en fait un an maintenant
voilà du coup
oui en plus donc en tout cas il fait un
gros tournoi aussi nguyen et ça se voit
sur cette partie et beaucoup de bonnes
choses quand même dur dur pour
pour marc andry aïe aïe aïe allez on
retourne voir la partie de fabiano
contre
contre duda c'est dur pour les deux
joueurs cette position extrêmement
complexe et on va arriver au bout du
bout du zeit
il a réussi à sécuriser tu sais si tu me
files a réussi à sécuriser s'il fait
tout reprend après
ça paie 20
mais c'est vrai que ce que je mange ses
trois le cavaliere 3 pu tenir la baraque
avec des plantes des quatre que c'est ça
un koala shirov jadis oui oui c'est
vraiment sympa le coude en guyane
franchement malheureusement ça ça va pas
trop dans notre
dans notre sens
mais c'était bien c'est un très beau
coup parce que franchement on voyait pas
vraiment quand comment les blancs
pouvaient prendre l'aventage way est là
en fait avec vous qu'on
voulait a pris du temps mais elle a
trouvé une très très belle astuce sur le
sur le 5 à l'essai e5 c'est un peu
étonnant est ce qu'il avait anticipé
bull qui le temps qu'il a appris je
pense pas
il n'y a pas tout anticipé mais bon mec
est très très fort aussi
et la bafin designer dans cette position
stouff
ça a été hyper chaud hein
je suis en prend lundi dernier coup là
d'une secte on pensait que caruana
allait réussir à à dégommer
le roi de deux duda
ouais
pas réussi à passer dans cette position
pourtant là à ce moment là on se dit ça
va le faire il ya vraiment beaucoup
d'initiatives un souffle sur le roi
blanc mais la cabane de duda tenu le
choc encore une fois spécialisée dans
les les abricotiers
le gars duda
elle aime bien mais il n'aime pas le
petit château habituel lui veut des
hébergements un peu plus exotiques le
gars duda pour son roi et du coup il a
fait un truc un peu à larache mais il
s'en est pas mal tiré un souffle dans
l'histoire incroyable
il s'est pas fait bercer
comme pied c'était genre une capacité à
se défendre et à ses monstrueuses et
franchement on sait plus on l'aurait
perdu dix fois oui plus facilement ouais
ils ont capacité de défendre les
positions qui est vraiment je trouve
très très impressionnante et dont on
voit encore il faut qu avoir acquis
encore raide son adversaire et j'ai
l'impression que que chaque partie c'est
rebelote pour kavanagh
bon cette position elle et
elle est beaucoup moins rigolote que
tout à l'heure parce que c'est beaucoup
plus difficile d'attaquer le roi de new
dance et un
k way j'aimerais bien le dévissé mais je
peux pas j'aurais bien voulu tu vois
souffert quelque chose comme tour
concède trois pions prendant prend et
mène mon cavalier 1,5 à terme mais là il
ya des tours france et 5 1 dans cette
ligne
voyez un taux français 3 tout ça c'est
pas c'est pas ok pour le moment et
valider la mais après d'un prince et
trois pommes je me prends pour penser ça
donc si je peux sacrifier mais je prends
pas tout de suite et je tourne mais je
pense que du coup j'ai pas sacrifier et
montrer mon intention mon adversaire
je jouerai bien tour indirects peut-être
mon projet le tout repose de l'autopont
ces cinq là peut-être les gens n'ont pas
tous compris ce qui se passait à tout
repenser sa vague regardez
il ya le vis-à-vis d'am-dam sur une dame
non protégés du coup mon pions ne pourra
jamais la dame peut prendre vous me dit
vous pouvez me dire ça voit la même
chose mais là la dame adverse il a le
trait c'est trop fort donc j'ai tous les
coups j'ai ça j'ai ça ça pour gagner la
tour up enfilade ou la double attaque la
brèche le fair play soit
quand la
tranquille
vous voyez là faut pas s'exciter
c'est pourtant la bonne idée
d'en vraiment la bonne idée
alors d'un coup bon après c'est qu'à une
pression que relativement désagréable un
moyen pour les blancs quand même le roy
qui loue vert le cac vers le froc et
fort un jour pousser des pions a et b
le roi noir qui au final un plutôt bien
défendu
et donc on voit la jauge qui est à peu
près égale on voit qu'il a un petit peu
raté un kill rupture des choses
peut-être mieux avant mais mais j'ai
quand même envie de donner un regard
noir aux parties
du courgain noir maintenant qu'ils ont